Grace and I'm going to be covering the
pre-game tonight
um I'm a YouTuber here at the audacity
Network unfortunately Paul couldn't make
it today so I'm stepping in sorry to
disappoint but it's still going to be a
great show we've got some lovely guests
here today and yeah let's get straight
into it couple of announcements before
we turn to our lovely guests
um first of all go subscribe to my
Channel at Christine Grace Smith I have
a series over there called debunking the
lunacy where we look into some of the
Ridiculousness that our society has to
offer and I basically tell you why it's
so ridiculous so if that sounds like
your cup of tea go check it out also be
sure to subscribe here at just pearly
things as well and obviously if you're a
fan of pearl you can keep up to date
with the pregame and pearl daily
and fellas and ladies I guess are you
sick of always having to be the one to
go up to women
do you wonder why women give you no
attention well courtesy of the audacity
Network we have the ultimate babe magnet
click the link in the description to go
get your women shouldn't vote t-shirt
okay
is everyone sitting comfortably
right let's begin we're going to go
around the room I want you to introduce
yourself say your name age and
relationship status okay and a fun fact
about yourself
okay so um uh my name is Solomon Buchi I
am 27 and I'm married
that's a fun fact uh what the fact that
I'm married okay one right now
um hi everyone my name is adiola Solomon
Bachi and I'm married as well
um I'm 27 as well and fun fact
um I can do this like weird thing with
my eyes with my left eye can we see it
creepy but it's like I can just contract
it like
oh my gosh okay no the pressure
maybe we'll come back to it we'll come
back to it go ahead
hi my name is IBI Lola
I am 22 years old and a fun fact about
me is that I am learning my seven
language
oh wow what do you speak already I
thought I speak French German
wow in English wow and what's the
seventh one that you're learning I'm
trying to learn Portuguese wow okay
that's very impressive go ahead it's
interrogation boss I am 26 and a fun
fact it's always the same I was born in
a Mercedes
for real foreign
[Laughter]
well I'm wearing my fun facts so I'm the
first Muslim female in hijab uh Miss
Great Britain finalists ever since it
launched in 1945 so yeah well done
thank you so much
amazing
my name is Jerome derush
I'm 35.
and my fun factor is I'm a singer actor
fashion designer and I like to call
myself an all-round entrepreneur
what's your business
what I do I'm a mentor I Mentor young
kids and adults um also working with
people with mental health and a
motivational speaker my main one of my
main things is um singer I've been
singing since like six oh wow yeah does
it run in the family or is it just you
my dad can sing but I'm the one that's
taken off with it yeah I come from a
family of singers so you would think I
can sing yeah it sounds like a cat yeah
it's really not fun you don't want to
hear it go ahead uh my name is dng dirty
cash
um I'm 37
um I'm 37. I'm a single Pringle
um I just
um a fun fact about me I've just uh
recently finished writing a full-length
feature film that I'm hoping to start um
put it into work next year
um as long as that I'm a creative I'm a
self-taught Trader
um and um what's the film called uh it's
called blood and crypto okay
um uh and I'm a rapper as well I've got
some music coming out in the fourth
quarter this year guided until next year
I'm just trying to do my thing just get
up in life you know all sorts of avenues
no fair play fair play okay so today's
episode is based around the question do
feminists crave destruction so I'm gonna
go around the room and I want to get
your honest thoughts don't feel that you
need to censor yourself here we're all
about the truth so we'll start here and
we'll go around do feminists crave
destruction
um I think it really depends on like
what what I would like what's what's
destruction here what kind of
Destruction can can you actually like
standard definition to destroy something
I think so okay why do you think so
I I I think that the modern day feminism
that we see
um even though he claims to actually
fight for equality but we see a lot of
things that's really destroying women
who don't femininity
you can't tell women that you know they
should just do anything they want to do
and there is just no consequence because
it's all about Freedom like one of the
ways to destroy something is to tell
that thing that it is free and there are
no consequences even men we are not free
we still have consequences for the
things that we do so I just think that
yeah yeah I just think that feminism is
not really helping women in this day and
age so we see things like for example
I think I was reading a tweet the other
day online and a young woman was saying
that she has been craving to get married
at 25. and I saw that a lot of feminists
actually came from her they were like at
25 you're thinking about marriage like
you are too young and in my head I'm
just like 25 but it's okay for a woman
or for a young girl who's 17 to have
only fans
it's fine for her to you know get to
have a baby it's fine for her to go
naked online all in the name of
empowerment so is it really empowering
women or is it really tearing women down
I think he's really tearing women down
though yeah and what do you think
um so I would say like
I guess I would like to make a bit of a
distinction so I think
what feminism is today as in modern day
feminism
I would say yes as well
um because I feel like modern day
feminism as it is today is quite toxic
um and and yeah it it just and and I and
I think that the the and I think what it
kind of destroys is just what the
essence of Womanhood and being feminine
and and actually actually owning that
and being proud of that
um amongst other things but yeah that
that those are you think it destroys
being proud of femininity
yeah yeah I would say so
um because like like a a a a trending
thought is that oh um
um like uh
women can do everything that a man can
do and all of that
um and
what
I do kind of understand the sentiments
but
you know that there's a different that
there's a reason why we are different
why the why the genders are different so
um yeah that that that is that is what I
would say yeah cool
go ahead all right also I am a gen Z so
my perspective on feminism is a bit
different
I believe that we gen Z we don't really
see things as it was before and the
feminism for me personally it's more
having the
the freedom of living my truths doing
whatever I want being a working mom or
being a full-time mom uh just a great
balance and everything and I believe
that that's what the Jersey people want
more the type of fun I agree that gen z
uh likes the idea of my truth I'm also
gen Z I definitely see that a lot and
yeah
cool amazing
um I would agree with the question to be
honest I think it destroys the mentality
of people who are in
the new generation
yeah
that's my view
go ahead
so
I'm just gonna disagree with everyone
here see the thing is it's it's the way
you phrase the question itself saying
that feminism is disruptive right it's
asking is feminism destructive okay see
the word destructive already it's a very
kind of like extreme word to do to use
to describe that it's very kind of like
the other end of the scale
feminism if we talk about you know the
right from the beginning from history
when it came about its purpose is to
empower women okay that's like
empowerment and the use of Destruction
that that was not the intention of it I
don't think that was you know the aim
when
um you know women wanted to go to
university they couldn't go to
university
um when women you know
um weren't allowed
um to go to work you know there was a
common misconception that they just had
to stay home look after the kids
obviously as time went on you know women
more and more demanded rights in all
aspects in all areas of life so I don't
think like the word saying that
um is destructive was not the original
intention of feminism do you think it's
changed over time yes do you think it's
perhaps turn a bit more negative now or
do you think that it stayed the same
um I feel yeah it has kind of like got
not 10 negative but it's got brought
more negativity to it would you say it's
been slightly tainted yeah that's that's
probably the better uh choice of words
okay okay no I I hear what you're saying
I'm actually going to get into that
topic in a bit so I'm really glad that
you brought up the historical context go
ahead um I don't really have that much
of a view on it but I do believe in the
society that we live in that with some
women that are not at peace
um if they are given some sort of
empowerment they just run with it and I
do believe it's those that are not at
peace within themselves and crave it a
lot more and just take it to a different
degree
um yeah that's it really and on the
other perspective I just believe that
everyone's equal that's the way I see it
at the end of the day so we're all able
to be given an equal fair chance to say
and to do things and I wouldn't say that
when people say men play their role
women play their role
I wouldn't separate it like that like
like it's a stigma I'll just say
everyone can be in position and just be
equal with one another but I do believe
that there are a lot of women out there
that are not at peace and the moment
they're given an opportunity they just
take it to a different degree do you
believe that men and women have certain
things that say men are better at than
women and women are better at than men
do you think there's qualities that are
masculine and feminine many many things
say well I was gonna say just when you
were saying the whole equal thing I just
want to grasp obviously we all have
equal innate value as human beings right
we can all agree that and I completely
agree with that yeah yeah but I just
want to get your perspective so you you
think that men and women have different
qualities that perhaps they're better at
yes but it doesn't deplete your actual
value as a human being yeah yeah okay
makes sense what do you think I just
think that obviously like over time the
more options that was given to women
there like like I was kind of second
what he says about
um that basically
not us being equal or nothing like that
but at the same time that
I feel like they run with certain things
that can make things destructive just
I'm saying like some of the opinions of
how how they look at things you say I'm
saying can you think of any examples
um not straight off top but I mean like
if I could if I could I'm putting you on
the spot yeah not off top but I mean
like for instance like this whole thing
that happened with roblers with him
kissing a girl at the World Cup for
instance like I don't really see that
like I think that was taken wholly out
of context and the media just run with
it to say I'm saying because for
instance like
I don't really see anything wrong with a
man trying to embrace a woman just so
I'm saying in that kind of celebrity in
and
I like the word to say and that kind of
um
that circumstance where they were
celebrating you see what I'm saying and
I think the feminists have now taken
that out of context and to the point
where the man's losing his job and he
was actually supporting a woman's sport
to see what I'm saying so I kind of feel
like that kind of that that kind of
example there is where I can see things
getting destructive you see what I'm
saying where we kind of you you seem
like you're itching to counter back yeah
sorry I know I just wanted to finish
obviously when he said that he don't you
said that you don't see anything wrong
with that with him giving her a kiss
okay no no no they both in Britain not
just him giving her this she she kissed
him they both Embrace if you've seen a
video they both Embrace each other
there's no there's no look of disgust
after when he was on the team but she's
on a team bus they're all laughing and
talking about kissing because like it
was it was filled as a joke after after
the whole of the whole issue started I
don't know what feminists were in her
ear or who told her this is not or
whatever but at the time there was
nothing wrong with it and then all of a
sudden now
it's blowing up in the media my my guy's
losing his job and she's now back in
she's being backed by the the the fa and
all these other things when to be honest
like if you look at it like this yeah
like a man's kissed a woman out of like
I say in of celebrating the Spain of
world won the World Cup now
we get we get thrown we get thrown all
kinds of things in them in in the media
and and soaps of like gays kissing
lesbians all of these other things and
that's thrown in our face you see what
I'm saying like as the norm and
something that was the norm as a man
just embracing a woman it's been it's
been it's been escalated into something
so dramatic and devastating that these
two people you know
facing different kind of circumstances
or something that's so normal sorry can
I just go back to one point then so you
said like
um so is she making it up then so
because you said you said that it looked
like and obviously appearance is is
something you know uh subjective to to
the viewer so you said like it looked
like that she accepted it that she was
fine it doesn't look like that that's
what happened in the moment they both
embraced each other there was no look of
disgust at him he didn't there was
nothing so obviously somebody has put
has then gone and said something
somebody's in her ears
what would be the purpose if you get
kissed in the Moment by somebody you
don't want to be kissed by you're
initially going to have a reaction to it
so I'm saying
they're both in a celebratory moment of
him him embracing her for winning the
World Cup and she's obviously happy that
she's won the World Cup and she's happy
in that moment so why would there and
there be an issue of him just pretty
much embracing her out of Happiness not
not necessarily not necessarily that
like immediately that she would have a
discuss she might have been a surprise
and she might have been shocked and she
didn't know how else to handle it
because she knows the cameras are on her
so if she were to look in any sort of
way cameras are never here in any sort
of way maybe she she was surprised and
shocked about it there's no surprise
what would be the gain what would be the
gain for her to go public about that and
also you're saying that it's the norm
it's a feminist thing obviously look at
the media now they're trying to shut
down everything that's heterosexual you
say I'm saying we see him more we see
more gay things on TV nowadays than we
see heterosexual things and anytime that
does happen it seems to be a problem and
I don't really understand what I want to
I just want to pause there I want to get
everyone's perspective on that because I
think I think it's good that we will
address this for you to get your point
across
do you think that heterosexuals are
being sort of depleted in the mainstream
media what I mean by that is do you
think that what he's saying is correct
you think that homosexuality and things
like that is promoted more than heteries
what does everyone think yeah I think I
think it's being brandished a lot more
now so that would imply that it's right
yeah they're talking about that more
than the street kids are bound to know
more about it than you the way how this
is in the schools now so really intrude
you why should it even be in the schools
for the kids tonight so I'm saying if
it's not an agenda why are kids being
told these things does anyone disagree
does anyone does anyone here think
that's heterosexuality and straight
sexual orientation is is shown the most
in in the media or do we all agree that
it is the the homosexuality that's shown
the most
look at all the programs that we have
from the soups to the films now there's
always some kind of gay storyline or
something that is or some kind of sex
scene or you know what I'm saying so we
can't say that it's not because if
you're not watching news or the media
then
you're not you know what I'm saying like
it's prevalent it's very prevalent final
question on this particular issue
does anyone here think that that's a
consequence of feminism or is it
something else if it's something else
what is it
um I actually think that I I wouldn't
really directly like Ping it on like
feminism but we need to understand that
feminism there is so much
intersectionality with feminism right
and feminism incorporates like the the
rights of like gay people the rights of
them the you know like the rainbow
people and all of that stuff that's just
because it's feminine uh because
masculinity doesn't have any type of
like masculinity is about males
betraying their strength and you know
their love for women I'm saying as well
so you can't really then come and then
say that it doesn't femininity doesn't
play a part in that it does but
femininity is is very different to
feminism so just just let him finish let
him say what yeah yeah so so I think
that there is there is a part of
feminism there because largely modern
day feminists actually believe that
um I mean they literally believe that a
man can be a woman right they believe in
things like that and the ideology is
very is just very open like they run
away from the non from the binary you
know exactly so so when you run away
from the norm what is that saying
because that's what we know just I'm
saying like if you're gonna change the
norm then you're changing something that
is originally
comes in its natural form so does anyone
disagree does anyone disagree and think
that homosexuality uh being promoted in
the mainstream media is completely
separate from feminism
yeah I think it is separate from the
premises I because I also am an actress
like that's my career my pressure and I
do agree with him on that sense that it
actually is kind of like in every single
single like film you see now there is
something like it has to be included in
there and I don't I think it's not
nothing to do with feminism it's more to
do with kind of representation it's
representation yeah and also kind of
like especially now like
um in mainstream um media uh and film
especially in the film industry there's
a lot of push now for diversity there's
a lot of push for like representing
everybody because that's what is their
prevalent in the streets and I think
it's just only for that reason why like
how you're saying that it's got to be
there somewhere so
yeah do you think it's separate yeah
yeah okay I still feel so yeah can I can
I ask you a question though sure what is
feminism to you
in fact yeah what is feminism to you
because I really don't want to go with
the dictionary definition like I just
want to add on on to that do you
acknowledge that feminism to you might
be different to what feminism actually
is well yeah it's different to everybody
because he did mention a comment he did
mention a comment that feminists uh
belief that men could be like women so
which you may not as someone who
identifies as a feminist yeah yeah yeah
but the point still stands yeah a lot of
feminists too and you can agree with
yeah okay
yeah okay cool cool
if you are agree that or if you think if
your definition of feminism is quite
very different from what we see then I
mean I understand that you have the
privilege to call yourself a feminist
however it's not sorry please I don't
actually call myself anything I don't
label myself as anything there are views
from the feminist point of view and the
reviews from other points of view so I
don't actually like oh okay call myself
a feminist I don't actually call myself
anything I'm not one of anything I
believe in if the views make sense then
I will believe in that I don't believe
in one particular thing or one
particular party or one particular point
of view I believe with whatever makes
sense I believe in actually logic uh so
you know you know how like obviously in
this country we have political parties
uh like conservative labor you know all
the rest of them
um I don't go with a party I go with
whoever's that has the best uh policy
exactly
okay cool um because the reason I asked
you is
um like modern day feminism is a mad
house right yeah like you said when he
started off right it's about like
helping women it's about you know
advancing and yeah encouraging women and
by the way I really really believe that
we are all identical in value so I don't
think that I'm actually Superior to a
woman you know fundamentally every human
life matters right however in modern day
feminists are the people who actually
advocate for the freedom of sex work
they are the people who advocate for the
freedom of certain just very very
disturbing things that you can't even be
destructive but yeah yeah right right I
don't know about 200 years ago because I
wasn't there talking about now feminism
back then was better than today bro you
see what I'm saying so like like if
we're gonna start talking traditionally
like women was had a lot more better
qualities They Carried their self a lot
more better they understood what it what
it was to hold down the house women
don't want to hold down the house we're
gonna get into that we're gonna get into
the the value that women bring in in
2023 but since we're all talking about
history
um I'm gonna do things a little bit
different to Poe I've actually done some
research that I wanted to bring with me
here today so I present to you all
exhibit a so we're all here pretty much
it seems in agreeance that feminism was
founded in in a pure cause and that it
was to help women so surely the people
who invented feminism you would think
had women's best interests at heart and
weren't after destruction everyone here
thinks that yeah yeah okay well this
might shock you because I also thought
the same for a very very long time that
the people who created feminism actually
weren't nice people who wanted the best
for everyone and just wanted equality
okay here's what what really happened so
Kate Miller she was an American feminist
author and artist uh she is the founder
of the National Organization for Women
her sister Mallory was invited to one of
the first meetings that established the
National Organization for Women so this
is a feminist group that has been around
since the start of the feminist movement
and they basically pioneered the whole
movement
at this meeting they gathered around a
large table with Kate Miller the
chairperson and she opened the meeting
with the following back and forth
recitation so this is how the beginning
of the meeting went
why are we here today she asked to make
Revolution they answered what kind of
Revolution the cultural revolution
how do we make Cultural Revolution by
destroying the American Family how do we
destroy the family by destroying the
American patriarch and how do we destroy
the American patriarch by taking away
his power and how do we do that by
destroying monogamy and how do we
destroy monogamy by promoting
promiscuity eroticism prostitution and
homosexuality comment
so this proceeded with a long discussion
on how to advance these goals by
establishing the National Organization
of Women uh the the lady who was there
the leader's sister says it was clear
they desired nothing less than the utter
deconstruction of Western Society
now anyone here can argue well it was
one person perhaps her and her sister
had an argument and that's why she's
saying all of this because you know
we've got to be we've got to be fair
it's just hearsay at this point another
woman who was there and actually a
feminist she's a feminist herself uh her
name is Phyllis Chesler she's a
psychologist feminist and author in her
book Politically Incorrect she says the
following about the woman who ran this
meeting Kate Miller had a shitload of
charm and in the beginning a commanding
presence but she also had periods in
which she didn't sleep she raged to
others attempted suicide and exploited
her groupies all while feeling
victimized by them she couldn't be
counted on to remain Lucid at press
conferences she also fell in love and
tried to have her way quite aggressively
with woman after woman including me and
most of the women in the movement were
incredibly broken by mental illness and
drug abuse
it was that time of the month the reason
I have brought this up is because I too
had the same belief that feminism
perhaps over time has become tainted and
things have gotten out of hand and now
it's got to an ugly Place how long ago
was this how long ago yeah I really want
to know how long ago was this it was in
the it was before uh it would have been
it was before
1930 I want to say that this is 1930.
someone someone in the chat needs to
find out because I don't have the dates
and I'm probably if that was good but
this is the founder of the National
Organization for Women which is a
pioneering group in feminism and one of
the first waves of feminism since 1930.
what's really interesting is when I was
researching for this
um it's very hard to find this you you
have to go on I don't know if you guys
know like DuckDuckGo it's like an
alternative to Google and you have to
like change your country if you look it
up in America or in the UK it's very
hard to find but when I changed uh my
country I tried all different ones I
tried like Bulgaria Russia and a few
others when I looked from then those
countries this information was was
available but the point is that it's
it's hidden from us and I think that's
what feminism's aiming to do I think it
doesn't want us to know the true Roots
because I believe if you if you stand
for a movement right and and you say
you're a feminist you deserve to know
exactly what it is that you're
identifying with right definitely
because otherwise you're going around
and saying oh I believe in feminism
because you believe feminism is all
about equality and inclusion well does
anyone here think that this conversation
sounds like equality and inclusion
because to me okay this is why you've
asked about the the use of uh the word
destructive this is precisely why the
question is worded that way because at
least to me it seems you'll have your
own opinions to me it seems that the
foundation of this movement was in fact
all about destruction they're honest
about their gender anyway I'm saying
like at least and what you said about
um you know homosexuality being promoted
in the media and you made the very fair
point of you know well it's all about
representation
well I would argue that Society tends to
follow like you said Brands trends that
they see and I think rather that Society
has changed and the media has conformed
as such
I think actually the media has changed
because this agenda took precedence and
Society followed and I think when you
you know I'm speculating here I I don't
know anything about being a homosexual
and I don't think anyone else here does
either so none of us can say for sure
but based on the evidence
and I have more research
it seems that things like homosexuality
promiscuity eroticism has been promoted
more and more and more under the guise
of feminism and that it's about
empowerment when really it's about
destruction
that's that's that's just that's what
they said and they were trying to
destroy the The Happy Home which is it
comes in Destroy men like before you
even said men I knew men was coming into
the whole territory just said I'm saying
because obviously it's written by women
so I have a point because I have been
thinking about it lately about feminism
in our society and uh one as personally
when I think about something I like to
go in the root of it what have caused it
and me personally uh because I'm also a
person who is very spiritual I believe
that it came from the imbalance of the
masculinity energy because I believe
that masculinity is the First Energy it
is a big energy and it is
something that set the tone it is an
energy who do who is aggressive who is
dominant so we have also noticed that
inner most of time
how can I explain it
the richest and biggest
powerful men in the society they go for
a type of woman and those women have
also certain type of characteristic so
if in the society women are having a
type of behavior where they are overly
sexualizing themselves and having
behaviors that we um
character is sticking into not being
submissive isn't it that um that the
masculinity is having a problem men have
issue of directing of taking initiative
of
some men are just meant easily
manipulated so I'm saying through
different means yeah so I'm saying yeah
like if you really like a woman and
she's putting it on you yeah then you're
gonna you're gonna fall to your feet to
a certain degree you're gonna crumble
and get soft to say I'm saying that
knows what he wants and sees through all
that he ain't buying yeah that's what
I'm saying because a man is a man a
manly man look at you like woman latch
you ain't you ain't just gonna listen to
all if you're a real man and you've been
brought up to know how to look after a
woman and treat a woman like nothing a
woman's gonna bring to you is gonna like
have you fall in at yourself I'm saying
like as a man like you're going to
project your energy onto a woman just
say I'm saying and a woman should know
how to like take gratitude in that you
see what I'm saying
but what I want to really emphasize is
that you talked about a man who is
confident yeah but all men confident
yeah but look if you're not all men are
confident yeah the thing is I would even
argue do men
can men be confident in a world where
masculinity is
punished yes yeah exactly
yeah
I'm saying don't be sitting out here
talking about oh yeah she took my power
away from me when she cheated because
bra like the [__] ain't gonna stop
till the casket drops so why are we out
here living in fear of what's going to
happen to us just say I'm saying
everybody sits their mopes after their
ex and what really intruding there's
always someone better which I'm saying
we live in a world of how many millions
of people you're gonna let one person
affect your life you see what I'm saying
you're gonna sit down and feel like you
cannot disconnect like look how many
friends we had from primary school to
secondary school to call it that we
don't know we don't even chat to you no
more what did we cry over them was we
sitting down balling talking about uh
Johnny or Tiffany or no we didn't
they're going on with their life now and
you're doing you so to be disconnected
from a human being that doesn't bring
any kind of prevalence or value to your
life it's stupid you're out there
wasting your time like time is money
my clothing line is called no vision
seems impossible because I think things
that I want to do in life and I'll make
it happen until I can't do it and
there's no blood in my veins for me to
run and do and Achieve things in life
I'm going to get it I don't care if if
you're in my pastor you're my present
[__] I'm saying I'm going to get it
whether you're riding with me or you're
not I don't need a woman to be telling
me what to do because I've got my own
brain and we've all been grown and known
what's right from wrong you see I'm
saying so if we're not following these
things and people are acting like raw
like if you're not learning from your
own mistakes or others then who are you
learning from you see what I'm saying
like in a straight up real like
everybody has their different agendas
and where they want to go in life follow
your path but just like we said don't be
trying to don't be trying to be toxic in
other people's life you see what I'm
saying and that's all it is
yeah so is it also not the question that
we are losing a bit the sense of our
society and the purpose of Our Lives
because we can clearly notice a very big
unbalance in all the energies
masculinity femininity dominance and
feminine and feminine and um
and also in our economy is it not that
we are also over stimulated and losing
our humanism I agree going basically I
completely agree with you
and I don't actually think I think
there's an individual level that we can
all take upon us to make a difference
however
this was all by Design This has all been
implemented you know it started with
these women who who sought out to
destroy things and actually when we look
into the history of feminism which
includes the promotion of of
homosexuality and the promotion of
promiscuity eroticism you know the dawn
of contraception all these different
things and you know it sounds really
far-fetched when we say it but actually
when you're looking at this one thing
sorry I didn't want to cut off but I had
it also to say that we need to
understand that when we create also a
lot of imbalance
I believe that is all a marketing
because you can only subtract money from
the person who is not confident like you
can see with the knowledgeable or not
knowledgeable about it you understand
how we set a lot of money from women
especially black women for example
so I believe that all this is like said
stuff created for ETC but it's a it's a
power game I believe some people for
attention as well only the you know
attention power only the the people who
are smart and uh understand to not lose
themselves will not get into all those
situations and also to go back to the
point of of representation and obviously
if we look at Beauty as well I I agree
in fact it's the it's the weaker people
who are more susceptible to it and I
think actually that area is somewhere
where representation has been weaponized
because you will have people who weigh
300 pounds on the front page of Sports
Illustrated magazines and they paint it
under the Skies of representation when
really it's if you tell people who look
unhealthy that they look beautiful
they're then gonna buy those products
exactly it's all marketing and it's
about and it has nothing to do with
actually what's good for that person
it's not even about fat shaming
because I I truly believe you that like
health is wealth and everybody knows
that if you look after and take you can
only enjoy your wealth so long as you're
alive exactly and and everybody knows
that if you take care of your body then
your due to see your body
I don't know walk faster or carry more
things or just even on a whole have a
longer lifespan just say what I'm saying
because we all know what fat brings it
can bring all different kinds of
conditions and you know what I'm saying
you can even slow your whole process and
your whole mental stimulation and
physical stimulation to see what I'm
saying so I believe as well that
nowadays we have also redefined so many
things that even about health we don't
know what is what is being healthy
because we have redefine a lot of stuff
and we have a normal life no no no we
know what is healthy yeah we know what
it tells us what we do is we share we
shy a wave and add little things you
know what I'm saying but like even going
back to like for instance vegan and
plant-based things do we not know that
that like natural foods can cure natural
can cure conditions but we sit here and
we'd rather take a pills you see what
I'm saying and people shy away from the
natural thing things in life that we
should be doing whether it be dieting
going to the gym or just physically
taking care of yourself just what I'm
saying about a lot of people things
happen yeah things have changed a lot
though I would argue I I would argue
that you're right there is there is
common sense right but Common Sense
isn't common anymore and especially
coming from our Generations
unfortunately what feminism has done is
it has basically allowed for people to
be more indoctrinated when you
indoctrinate people basically people
have given options where they can
obviously be this gender that gender eat
this and that's what I'm saying it's
like when you give people options you're
spoil for Choice exactly so nobody's
actually thinking about the main root of
what we should actually be doing but
also because no one can and and the
reason no one can is because people no
longer have the ability to think because
they're so comfortable in our lives you
can go on your phone and oh I need
something Amazon Prime I'm hungry you
can go you know grab a takeaway and then
and people don't need to think
about how to survive when all of their
survival needs are met so I think
there's an element of certain people are
so indoctrinated to the point where they
don't know what's good for them I agree
with that but also I think a lot of it
is to do with people just don't care
because all of their basic needs it's
amazing yes yes they're content with the
life that they have but going back to to
feminism and one of the things that we
can acknowledge feminism has done is it
has allowed for promiscuity whether we
say this is in the name of empowerment
or whether we say it's degrading either
way can we all agree that promiscuity
has been
become much more popular most definitely
oh yeah 100 yeah okay we're gonna go
around the room again we're gonna start
here
do you think promiscuity is a bad thing
so do you think it's bad for women or do
you think it's empowering for women
it's bad
um yeah it's it's bad the reason I said
it that way was in my head I was just
trying to imagine someone who would say
it's good we've had a lot of panels here
where you would be really surprised yeah
like I was just trying to like imagine
like who would actually see that it's a
good thing
um first of all I'm actually a Christian
right and I have very um biblical World
Views right
and even
I can't keep my faith aside to like make
examples but even if I wanted to keep my
faith aside like even traditionalists do
not believe that that everyone deserves
a piece of you right you can't just be
like sex is such a very sacred for real
it's it's a very it's it's a very deep
thing yeah yeah it's infinite like
different yeah it's it's definitely not
something you want to go around like
giving to everyone
exactly like yeah and and that's why
marriage was created like like marriage
is actually that place that you can you
can have safe sex
a lot of times people are like saying
stuff like you know using you know
um condoms or whatever but condoms
cannot actually protect you from the
repercussion of having sex out of
marriage right you need to actually have
like there's just a security that that
you have when you have sex in marriage
right
um and and I guess that's actually why
you need to marry right so I think I
think talking about the institution of
marriage is actually really important
here um because it's important to to
note the the conversation uh that we
referenced earlier National Organization
of Women and what they founded
um they were all marxists so they were
all Communists so they don't believe in
the institution of marriage they believe
that marriage is is basically a way to
to privatize people and it's all based
on a wrong world view because it's based
on the idea that back in caveman times
um all the men slept with all the women
and that's how things were
um but we can trace back history and we
know that actually marriage maybe it's
not just maybe not so much as an
institution but marriage has been around
since the dawn of human beings and human
beings have always paired to one another
Adam and Eve yes yeah yeah I mean
some people might not use that example
but even if we go down you know to
Medieval Times or from the children even
before that caveman times people still
coupled together exactly there was
always a king and a queen it wasn't a
queen and a queen it was yeah as I'm
saying so so what do you think uh is
promiscuity uh an empowering thing or is
it a a bad thing I think it's definitely
a bad thing and one of the reasons why I
think it's a bad thing is that
I I think I think it's it really it
really destroys like the identity and
the self-esteem of women because because
like a a lot of a lot of women maybe
maybe promiscuous and may think that oh
yeah you know it's my body and and I'm
doing what I want with it but they're
actually causing more damage to
themselves
um that like and and kind of giving
themselves more baggage
um um to deal with in the future
um so I definitely think that it is it
is a really really bad thing and it is
just so heartbreaking and sad that it's
actually being promoted as as something
good as as yeah no no you know this is
your body and you can you can sell it
but you
like like they're literally just
cheapening themselves like like that
they it it's like they don't know
they don't know
their true value
um their answer is a lot of the time
um
well you know people like the
suffragettes fought for me to be like
this and actually not like that yeah
actually when we look at their roots of
feminism yeah they're getting exactly
what they wanted they're promoting
prosecutions
because I'm I'm just I am happy to give
it to you after the show I was just a
shot that's why I bought it here today
because it is
crazy it's absolutely crazy
um but yeah what do you think do you
think promiscuity is a good thing or a
bad thing and so for me it's two things
once is um I believe that uh as I use
perspective on that and the second is
once again like she said value
and uh why do I see perspective because
I just searched the word and I saw that
one of the synonym of the words they
were
positivity of sexuality so what I mean
about that is that what promiscuous
positivity one of the synonyms is a
synonym was uh promiscuity was a
positivity of sexuality
so what I mean by that is that
uh everybody defined what sexuality is
for them and how they want to behave
themselves I believe in um freedom in
your sexuality but
you need to know your limit you need to
know why you want to do with your body
that's not Freedom though if if there is
a limit that you need to know don't even
finish because it depends what are
defined by
um
[Music]
freedom because I'm not talking about
Freedom me being as a me running a trend
on everybody for me personally is not
really a freedom because freedom for me
is a state of mind freedom is not
searching for validation freedom is
sitting as is me sitting and not caring
about me having to do a certain stuff to
be perceive us and to be validated to be
I don't know there is a boundary though
to your freedom
no having Freedom you're not going to do
certain things that some promise
in the real definition the Deep one is
having boundaries because if you have
boundaries you are free you know your
limit you know freedom freedom freedom
implies that you have a choice that is
unhindered right exactly yeah so I would
say
the women who are promiscuous
um let's just take the tip of an example
here on this show the only fans model
right yeah is she making that choice
based upon freedom because if she's
doing it based upon Freedom that would
imply that she knows why promiscuity is
now seen as an empowering thing in the
first place and no one here knew why
promiscuity was first promoted it was
promoted as a means to destroy the
family so for her to be free in the
choice of becoming an only fans model
she should know that right she doesn't
and that's what I'm saying and the
information is very hard to find but
like I'm saying is this perspective you
thinking that you're free because you
can do it only fun is your perspective
somebody else would think that not
having to feel to do an only fun is the
freedom I ask you like so do you believe
do you believe do you believe in good or
bad like do you believe that there are
certain things that we do that are
actually intrinsically externally bad
like just it's just bad or do you
believe in relative morality like do you
believe that you define what is right
and wrong to you
Azul personally
I have my own boundaries and I think
like it's a yes or no answer like do you
do you believe so I yes I believe that
in everything there's boundaries and
like I'm like I'm trying to even explain
um freedom is uh something that
everybody defined it in a different way
and for me is knowing your boundaries
and knowing what are your limits that's
when you are free so do you think you
are really answering the question dude
like I'm saying like yeah
as well because a lot of people are
cutting me off
you say like you have a point no I just
want to go back to your point when you
raise the comment about the only fans
model is she doing it uh because she has
Freedom uh I think probably the
intention is
I'd I think probably maybe you'd agree
with this you didn't because of money
because she wants to get money yeah of
course that's that's why she's doing it
the question I'm posing is that why do
you talk about that so like all of them
obviously because obviously both of them
are you know Christian obviously I'm
gonna oh I'm obviously missing him so
obviously
and the thing is
especially in Islam and all religion I
don't really like to talk too much about
it but there is a logical sense to it so
primary security what does it bring it
brings uh sexual diseases it brings
things like yeah unwanted pregnancies uh
uh unwanted you know adoptions so it
brings bad things that is why like
obviously in Christianity as well it's
not permitted so there's reasoning
there's a logic behind it yes yeah you
know uh shame to the family real
reputation
um a whole load of uh negative kind of
exactly examinations and dangerous
things dangerous the funny thing is that
prostitution was like according to
statistics I really kind of remember
right now I can actually check later
according to statistics most women who
became prostitutes before the modern
world were women who were stranded the
women who needed help right like no
woman stands up and say I want to be a
prostitute like it's empowering like
that's absolutely nasty like I I
understand I I I understand if based on
situation maybe she finds herself there
but but then with that prostitutes like
that they have shame but nowadays
now priding in prostitution and now you
know labeling courage yeah and
encouraging it like see how you said
like no woman right now was gonna say
yeah I'm a prostitute but they'll
they're gonna say it in words
I do only fans or like like only friends
is a real much shame around like you
said I'm saying like like I wouldn't I
wouldn't be one of these guys just be
like Rod you know I'll get Hella girls
and Rama Gigolo like that's my
profession like you said I'm saying like
how would I sound saying that like yeah
what do you do I'm a gigolo bro like
yeah come like it doesn't sound like
that's an old school
but I'm bringing it back like seriously
nice one of these ones where no one no
no you can't really take no pride in
being promiscuous and any any guy or any
girl that sees anybody moving
promiscuous knows the kind of qualities
that that person holds just say I'm
saying so you can't really you can't
really be getting down or be thinking
that somebody that's promiscuous or that
kind of action is going to bring any
kind of positive but then any kind of
situational relationship but then as as
much as my personal perspective though I
don't know as much as you know I frown
upon like promise greeting when it has
to eat women I do the same with men
right uh because I feel like it's it's a
conversation that's really like double
edged right um so number one we we look
at like sex work in the in the in the in
the in the society
if women don't sell men will not buy but
if Men Don't Buy Women will not sell
what's this right so I I understand the
cultural differences in the way we see
what women do and men do however I also
think that it's something that has to be
as much as there is no dignity in being
a prostitute I don't think that they
should be dignity for a man in actually
being a prostitute's client if that
makes sense so it has to be very both
sides of the spectrum it's not it's not
it's not a positive thing yeah the
reason I'm saying is is because there
are men who see you know the ability to
bag like you know a promiscuous woman I
think you you had another perspective
yeah um actually I just want to address
the point from from that from the mental
health perspective and I you or you're
obviously like into mental health and
I'm also as part of a Miss great we're
in finalist um I'm actually also an
advocate for mental health so I think a
lot of it also stems from like
um Mental Health health and Trauma and
Trauma so sometimes you know they they
don't actually know any other way out
and they actually they think they feel
like
um that's actually you know yeah and
they they feel like they have to do it
or in almost sometimes it's like they
have to feel something and to feel kind
of like the thing that they're missing
out on there was a I can't remember his
name for the life of me he was um like a
mental health guy and he was on a show
it wasn't Dr Phil but it was one of
those type of shows and he says you know
the majority he was talking about
um girls who were really sexually active
and we're talking girls under the age of
16.
um and he says you know the majority of
them when he says well why do you do it
their answer honestly it's heartbreaking
their answer is well he was nice to me
yeah yeah and that's the world we're
living in can I just say touching on it
because I'm listening to everybody I
just think it's vile I just think it's
yeah yeah I agree I've got two daughters
and I tell you now I've got seven kids
by the way oh wow and I love them dearly
I'm definitely congratulations that is a
number not many people can say these
days no no
um but you know I'm a proud father but
you know what it is like one of my
daughters is born on the same day as me
so that's the same extra yeah so my
birthday's in two weeks so yeah what a
great birthday present yeah but you know
what it is I'm very much touching on
like mental health like I must suffering
myself but I used to seek external
validation not touching on what you said
is very because I work in the hospitals
as well and I think with this how do you
pronounce the word promise yeah I just
think it's a bad image it's all about
following Trends it's all about it being
okay if it's what's in my daughters
could never they could never and also
what you said about money
um I would argue that I argue I would
argue it's actually a really dumb way of
making money because it's a bad business
model right you're only gonna sell so
long as you're attracted right they I've
said it in a previous video they fail to
acknowledge one day they're going to get
wrinkles yes one day the boobs are gonna
sag yeah and the pictures aren't gonna
sell so actually it's it's a bad
business model in itself and but the
root of it is is really quite sad
because the main reason that you said
that people are doing it is because it's
a lack of self-awareness they don't even
realize it's a bad thing and I think and
I think that you see regarding the
mental health side it's all about
validation with some people and that's
why I'm glad that you touched on mental
health because it's got to a point
they're not realizing and it could be a
thing it becomes a thing for that moment
tarnished tarnished your names but their
mental health is in such a way in a bad
place they're not realizing and it's all
about purpose and without no purpose you
have no sense of direction so if they
believe and deem that that's their
purpose they think it's okay only fans
it's just okay it's not illegal but it's
out there but it's being brandished like
it's okay well we live in a really
nihilistic world now don't we we live in
a world where people don't have meaning
I mean a few of you here have said that
you're religious I mean yeah that's
that's not common it's got a lot of
people don't have religion and in fact
what's really interesting to me just to
go back to the whole media trends thing
is that religion is villainized in the
mainstream media
um and I I don't think again I don't
think that's an accident in the same way
that you know promiscuity and and all
the things that come with it feminism in
the same way that we know you can go you
can fact check me on this we know that
feminism second wave feminism was funded
by the Rockefeller family who are like
one of the richest families in the world
and the CIA because it was going to make
them money yeah right so I then have to
question
I can't help it after knowing that I
have to question well why is it that
things like religion are demonized so
much in the media and why is religion
such as such a topic
the thing I'm telling you people shy
away from the things The Surreal I'm
saying what traditionally set us free
just could set us free okay people don't
want to be set which is which is purpose
whether it be in the form of personal
fulfillment or religion the point that
I'm seeking to make is that there is
there is no purpose check this girls go
on Instagram more than they go to church
a church is just accessible as Instagram
[Music]
I understand what you're saying but I
think it's deeper than going to church
so for me personally
I appreciate that you actually you know
said that like religion is so is so
demonized and the world isn't it yeah
the world views from religion like I
said I'm Christian obviously my wife is
actually Christian so the Christian
World Views are so demonized right and I
think that the problem is that we don't
want an absolute bearing of what is
wrong and right and obviously we know
that religion actually tells you that
this is right and this is wrong yeah and
because everyone would just wants
Freedom yeah yeah and because of the
media propaganda like people humans we
we want freedom but the sad thing is
that
we become really free when we understand
that we are not friends
free from what because government's
trapping you yeah
me personally when I'm dying when I die
I'm free that's when I'm free yeah
literally literally like like freedom is
is really not in being able to do
whatever you want to do it's in actually
having counsel to understand that what
you do have repercussions exactly and
avoiding the things that will bring you
bad you know effects right so yeah and
that's one thing that as a Christian
that we believe in and you strive to
live your life exactly so nobody wants
that nobody wants to nobody no everybody
wants agency right everybody wants
autonomy nobody and it's so
contradictory to me because a lot of
these people when they say you know what
yeah I am not I'm not a conventional
person I'm like then you need to just
create your world leave the government
of the Earth right because literally you
live in you live in a state like you
live in a country and that country has
rules they have regulations you're not
going to go to your employer and say you
know what yeah I I I I I choose to
identify Friday as my off day
yeah
yeah right right like you can't do that
because there is really no total freedom
in life yeah as Christians we believe
that we are free in Christ and and we'll
just be like yes so so that's that as I
have something to say uh once again like
uh you said freedom is about uh knowing
that you're not free enjoying what I was
saying being free is knowing your
boundaries
so what I was uh about to against as
well was about
um church and Christianality
is that one reason why I believe that is
also being demonized is because it's
become again like a five fast food type
of marketing once again we
because one thing I noticed that we try
to put every type of Industries in a
fast forward mode like a food we're
trying to
make money out of everything and people
try also to make money out of uh
religion because uh the sir um make a
point with religion is here to tell you
either if you have to do something or
not yes or no so we have people using
um Christianity to say to do to also to
say you need to do that for to have this
everybody has started using as well the
the religion for his own purpose for his
own advice Christianity has even changed
now and things of that shouldn't be
accepted within the religion are now
becoming yeah
it's depleting a lens but yeah yeah I I
understand I understand that there are
actually like bad eggs right in every
organization and every world view there
will be bad eggs but the question is or
my position is that if you really want
to do something you would find reason to
do those things now let me ask you a
question do you believe that there are
bad people in the society yes you
believe so why are you still part of the
society because you know what you want
to get from the society you know
yourself right so if you know that
you're true to yourself then be true to
yourself as a Christian or yeah just be
be true to yourself like I I understand
when people say stuff like you know a
lot of people are using Christianity to
actually cash out or make money and all
of that stuff that like what do you do
all right check this now in the church
here why is there promiscuity in the
church when it when it's supposed to be
a place of of of sacredness and and
spirituality and and and and and and
prayer which is something that should
lead you to be doing the right righteous
stuff in life yeah and but yet still we
have the pastor uh touching on kids yeah
sorry I just wanted you to elaborate
what do you mean what's going on in the
church yeah
no no no no
I I understand I understand if it's
actually happening like it's happening
and that's not what's supposed to be
happening
but the way you are sounding is as
though it's been normalized like it's
not been normalized yeah it's not being
nominal it's being normalized but it's
obviously prevalent because we're
talking about these kind of things so do
you mean that there is no church that's
good enough for people today oh they're
just like their own people at the same
time it's still prevalent within you you
say it's it's very common
um yeah
this is why it's being demonized because
we have a lot of examples of people who
are religious that are doing completely
opposite things to their religion here
we go that's why it's being demonized
yeah I just want to say a point on that
I agree with her when she says yes there
are people that are religious or claim
to be religious if they call themselves
that doing things that they should be
doing but in all religions okay
um we're not created perfect we are not
created as a perfect human being we were
created to make mistakes and we were
created to see are we gonna follow the
right path or we are we going to follow
the wrong path that's all this life is
is a test okay from whatever you know
spiritual thing you think of so um even
religious people make mistakes well like
you were saying what was happening in
the church because I was like what but
yeah even the most Pious of people they
make mistakes because they weren't
created perfect everybody everybody
everybody sins that's why you're given a
right to repent just what I'm saying
there's a difference there's a
difference between a sin and a mistake
two completely no no all sins
all sins or all mistakes are sins right
like if you like yeah but make a mistake
and be wrong but I don't know if all
sins are mistakes but not
inattentionally sometimes things are
done with intent okay so I'm saying
sometimes things are done and and
unbeknownst to just I'm saying oh you're
you're just ignorant or naive not to
know that you've made that and I think
the issue of intent is really important
especially when we're talking about
religions and you mentioned Bad Eggs you
know there's issues where bad eggs of a
religion the whole religion
and when we just to link this book sorry
I I really rate you know that session
you're wearing no no doubt because you
know what like it would be so hard for a
young Muslim woman to be seen as as as a
prevalent beautiful woman in this
society and in our culture just I'm
saying so that's why I fully rate you
for that stuff thank you and to be
honest I'm gonna show you like my
ex-girlfriend she was she was Muslim and
she's probably the best woman I've ever
had in my life do you see what I'm
saying but it's one of these ones where
because I'm not following that that that
spiritual wretch's path myself I
couldn't say to her you know what yeah
I'm gonna make you happy and marry you
because I can't go against the Green of
what I believe as much as I know what
she believes and as much as we had love
for each other and all these other
things that I couldn't then go and then
procrastinate and say yeah I'm gonna
take much harder and not be doing the
kind of things that I know I should be
doing if I'm going to become a Muslim
you say I'm saying so that all in it in
itself I had to leave that alone knowing
that I've got my own path in life and as
much as right I did meet somebody that
could could have changed my world
I have to do my own thing to say I'm
saying and I have to stand on my own too
that's what I'm saying and a lot of
people they don't they don't take the
time out to know themselves and they'll
just jump into things where they do then
go and make mistakes and then be
promiscuous and do these other things
because they didn't set the tone just
say what I'm saying so and setting the
tone like like intent is is very
important because a lot of people just
to
hone the conversation back to feminism
quickly
um a lot of people could make the
argument about feminism well you know
just because these women said what we
just discussed
um you know they could be the bad ex but
it it you're right it's all about
intention Christianity Islam religions
the intent behind them yeah was not
destruction it was uh you know faith
we don't right if someone comes out and
gives me a conversation like that that
happened and the basis of all religion
I'll put my hands on I think it is
destruction there's over a thousand
religions
right
I believe in God but I'm not tied to a
religion okay cool why do you even
believe in God like yeah like because
everyone comes from somewhere everything
in this room somewhere
it's common sense
but like you are not different from
people who believe in God
who believe in Jesus Christ there must
be a god up there somewhere I just don't
know what form it could be the war it
could be the Sun the Moon it could be
the microphone it could be me I don't
know what form God comes in people have
got different perceptions
can I can I just ask actually so you
said that you said that there are a
thousand religions out there but then
you said that that's destruction I don't
really understand your point though
that religion causes conflict you see
I'm saying the moralism
that of course there has been a lot of
travesties and a lot of Destruction that
has has happened when people have
disagreeing religions we can we can all
agree on that but my point is about
intent you know the intent of bit of it
as well the root of it I don't believe
is about destruction I don't think
people turn sorry not turn I don't think
people
the people that say put together the
Bible or I'm really sorry I don't know
much about Islam I don't know how the
Quran was put together okay so I'll just
tell you so was it a group of people no
so the words okay were said uh from uh
the angel isalam so you call him uh
Gabriel in Christianity uh to the last
prophet Muhammad so the words are
directly from Allah and it was then
transcribed and written down in the
Quran right so I just want to say
mention something about us just a little
bit just for knowledge because we're
talking about religion all the other
previous religions before Islam so
Christianity Judaism all of the all of
the books
all of that
and and all the profits as well so like
uh we say dawood it's David
um you say Jesus it's Issa okay it's all
the same prophets it's all this it's
actually all part of the same beliefs
the same religion even in the Bible the
Old Testament
um is is like if you compare it with the
Quran it's very similar okay so it's
only the difference very the last
difference is that Muhammad is the last
prophet after like um Jesus I I disagree
with that
um so so we don't believe that Jesus is
just a prophet we believe that okay
sorry yeah yeah so so so I think I think
that
even though there may be similarities
some similarities between the two
religions fundamentally they are
different because the basis of our
belief is that Jesus
um Jesus is the son of God who came down
to die for our sins
so so so so so we we believe that Jesus
is the son of God and that he is God so
so he he wasn't to us he wasn't just the
prophet and and literally that is the
basis of our faith so the point the
point that I'm I'm trying to make is
that
religion is very different to something
like feminism because religion can get
tainted by the idea of of say bad eggs
the point that I'm making is that
feminism wasn't tainted by Bad Eggs it
was created by Bad Eggs but religion is
always a very interesting topic but I am
gonna gonna cut the conversation there
because I want to move on to to the next
exhibit that I want to talk to you guys
about
um so we've also um before we move on I
just want to reiterate the rules can we
please stop cutting each other off when
someone is trying to make a point please
let's allow the person to make their
point and then if you want to respond
you'll be given a chance to respond
thank you king
um right so we all pretty much
think
agreed that we think promiscuity is bad
no I have an unpopular opinion go ahead
so although I
I do find that it's the grading
and it's disgusting however
um I have an unpopular opinion in terms
of it being good in a sense of
because it's a trend because this was
people doing then they're doing it for
chess I think it's a good thing that is
now being promoted because now we can
filter those people out in that sense so
it's a very very interesting filter them
out Health what do you mean by filter
those people so are you saying filter
the people who are being promiscuous
yeah the people who choose to do it you
you now know who's doing it so do you
mean like you know nothing about
degenerative degenerate behavior is
exactly so you would now know if you
want to facilitate yourself with realm
of those people or not it's a good thing
I'm now revealing themselves to that so
it's good but I think I I can't point to
that because I I really like that idea
in theory I think that that is a good
point but that is ignoring the point
that we made that the majority of women
who are promiscuous are doing it
I don't even know if it's the majority I
wouldn't say the majority I think the
majority now you're right it is because
it's a trend but there are people who we
acknowledged on the the mental health
side that you guys were mentioning
um
perhaps got into it very young and you
can't really I don't believe that you
can sit here and say that a 13 year old
being highly promiscuous because she's
experienced say uh no Father Figure in
her life and maybe some form of abuse
trauma
um I don't think we can disregard that
as as degeneracy uh because it just it's
too young I agree we won't disregard it
however these elements are going to
happen regardless because people are
going to end up in disadvantages
what's the solution and there isn't
really much solutions to it so you just
have to leave those people to it they're
just gonna have to be left behind and we
now know who they are I I think what
feminism has done is uh it's it's told
women that women can have sex like men
it's told women that they can sleep
around in the same way as a man does and
then that has no repercussions does
anyone here
disagree that sex is different for men
and women or do people hear does anyone
here genuinely believe that a woman can
have sex like a man and have
no emotional attachment with it I have a
very different point of view when it
comes to
um this type of um
uh
discussion because I don't even believe
that a man is allowed to sleep too much
around I don't see that that way because
me personally in my beliefs and the way
I think is that and men who have no
boundaries when it comes to sex you are
feminine to me you are not a man and I
cannot respect you unfortunately
this is how I see it so for me it's the
it's the it's the same thing
who is also sleeping around you are
being now masculine and a man a dominant
man a provider cannot take you on his
else because
you are being now the man you are trying
I think you you had a point to that yeah
first of all I'll say a man that can
hold his sexual pleasures is a
disciplined man first second of all
there are a lot of broken women out
there that use sleeping with a lot of
men as a coping mechanism or call him a
rebound and for that moment it makes
them feel good that's the bottom line
because there are women out there doing
it and because they are broken for that
time
because they can't control themselves
because of feelings and emotions they
just think okay let me call up an
ex-partner or this guy I might see in a
party and just do it and feel bad after
if they do so I also think it's an
Institutional problem so it's not taught
in schools that the experience of sex is
different for for men and women oh
that's gone out the window um this is uh
exhibit B
um so I'm gonna basically present to you
guys some some statistics um so the
first thing that I want to talk about is
pair bonding uh which I'm not sure how
many people here know about I didn't
know about it until I did my own
research because it isn't taught in
school in in school
at least here in Britain all your taught
is
when you start having sex make sure
you're protected and if you get pregnant
well there's an abortion and it's pretty
much that simple nothing is taught to go
specifically to say that there are
emotional consequences for you when you
have sex and there are emotional
consequences so hair bonding is a
biological neurological mechanism that
happens in all animals including humans
to form attachments this was first
arrived in 1987 in a study by Hassan and
Schaefer repeated sexual encounters with
multiple partners rewires the brain when
an individual chooses to engage in
casual transient sex Breaking Bond after
bond with each new sexual partner the
brain forms a new synaptic map of one
night stands and this pattern becomes
the new normal for the individual this
means it could make it harder for you to
permanently bond with someone this
happens for both sexes yes oxytocin is
produced at higher and higher levels
when repeating sex with the same partner
um however for women the levels are much
greater meaning the ability to pair bond
is negatively negatively affected at a
lower rate so here's some facts that
sort of corroborate with with that
information the national survey of
family growth collected in 2002 2006
2010 2011 and 2013 for women marrying
since the start of the New Millennium so
this is women who've got married since
2000. women with 10 or more sexual
partners were the most likely to get
divorced but this only became true in
recent years women with three to nine
sexual partners were less likely to
divorce the women with two partners and
women with zero to one sexual partners
were the least likely to get divorced
and that obviously is a direct link to
the ability to permanently emotionally
bond with someone
yeah go ahead no no what was your point
of the
reading that the sex is very different
for men and women and that we're not
taught this and I I think
I don't think that we would see the huge
trend of girls doing things like only
fans and and being more promiscuous as
in who they're actually sleeping with
um because I know I know many girls who
have you know are not personally but
I've heard of many girls who have these
notes folders of all the people they've
slept with and it seems like you know
like a frat house it seems like you know
something guys are doing we can all
admit that you know
I I don't agree with like with what you
said I don't agree that but promiscuity
uh is good for men or women I like what
you said a man who can control his
sexual desires to me that says that's
its discipline but men are generally
more promiscuous than women and and
unfortunately they can be because
there's there's less of a consequence
for them
um but I just think that there's a
there's a bit of an issue here where
women really want to think at least from
what I've seen watching a number of Pals
shows haven't been on the show a couple
of times myself a lot of women genuinely
do not want to accept
that for us sex is something very
different than it is for men that was my
point yeah I think women who should hold
it more sacred to measure it yeah like
you know I mean like I think as a
society everyone should treasure it but
I do think it's much more important to
women
I mean men like you said are naturally
more promiscuous men are more forfeit
about sex I I think but nowadays I think
with all these platforms that are coming
out and social media I think I think
women hold more more power when it comes
to the Forefront of sex you said I'm
saying so it it and and and and that
promotes promiscuous uh professori so I
I just believe that
it may not really really doomed in in
regards to
being sucked by women and and how and
actually I I would argue that it's
dooming women as well if we if we look
at the facts uh women are on
antidepressants more than ever before uh
we have less children we're having more
abortions 51 of us in this room so how
many of us are there one two three four
five
let's say two out of five to three out
of five of us will be single and
childless uh by 30. um we win custody of
children 90 of the times whether it's in
the child's interest or not uh we make
up 90 of consumer decisions so often
like he was saying men being doomed men
are men don't really get the say in
anything anymore and women reap all the
benefits of of divorce you know a lot of
men we're hearing more and more stories
uh being left completely with nothing
after after divorce and and often the
the number one time that a man is going
to commit suicide tends to be after
divorce and and after the children have
been taken from him so yeah I mean the
whole promiscuity thing is is dooming
men but your numbers the numbers don't
lag so I'm saying like fill out the
numbers like the amount of sexual
partners that women have leads to the
success of their relationships I'm
saying so if you if you know what you
want to do or how you want to be an
Earnest life then I guess you gotta
you know I'm saying live the ratchet
spot so next question on on the topic of
uh feminism and and do feminists crave
destruction
um
despite what we now know about the
history of feminism can anyone think of
anything that feminism has has done good
and has achieved yeah exactly what I
said it filters out to people you don't
want to facilitate yourself fair enough
yeah I think it's empowered women to a
certain degree you know like giving them
a lot more
uh I say I see more confidence and able
to talk about their feelings and what
they the positions they want to hold and
to say just what I'm saying like and and
the roles that they they should be
allowed to something because I from
certain or certain ages where women were
stopped from doing certain things and
being able to talk or even certain
countries drive what you know what I'm
saying so like it's given them a lot
more empowerment to a certain degree
yeah and I think that's a good thing but
I think sometimes it's taken I think now
it's a lot the more like I said The more
options they're given they start to
destroy [__] a little bit so I'm saying
and Things become negative instead of a
positive outlook yeah and I also think
even in the like corporately in the
corporate world it's it's it's given
women more exposure as well
um
um and yeah that so it's it it has been
positive in that sense I have a question
um do do does anyone on the planet
believe that when more women on Mars
should be in leadership roles
more women or what yeah like an influx
yes do people think that women should
be in leadership roles and should be
encouraged to be in leadership roles
depending so I I think yeah exactly I
agree with that and also yeah no it's
not it's not it's not a thing about
women being more in leadership roles
it's whoever is best for that yes
but they should have equal opportunity
the question is should women on mass be
encouraged to be in leadership roles
yeah they should be encouraged if they
have absolutely absolutely yeah but that
I I would have to add to that just made
the point it should be the best person
for your job but if
a lot of people would argue that things
like quotas or encouragement and
actually what things like quotas are
doing and not qualifying people who are
best for the job they're qualifying
based on identity politics no but his
his kind of point was encouraging to for
them to apply yeah
that's not my question my question was
should we as a society encourage
encourage and encourage women on mass to
be more in leadership roles so because
the reason why I asked that question is
if we do that then where does that leave
the men and then can we in the same
breath now say that men should be
leaders if we are encouraging all the
women to take up all the leadership
roles
um so I don't think that I don't think
that men should lead just because they
are men yes I understand that men are
actually very old they make better
decisions they're more logical
I wouldn't say men's no this is the
problem because now the reason and the
reason I brought up this question
specifically because I wanted to hear
that kind of answer so here's the thing
who is designed by designated a man or a
woman a man a man yeah my point is so if
a man is designed to be a leader why are
we now choosing as a society to
encourage more women because like wait
let me look at my point instead of
encouraging the men who are not being
leaders to step
check this over the age of time man I've
been running things yeah and man already
been running things that's what I'm
saying so it like it's like but now
they're slacking
something about slacking yeah men have
been teaching women that's what I'm
saying because they've been running the
thing so they couldn't have learned from
women if they if they weren't running
that is what I'm saying men have been
teaching but what it is the power's it
it's like the powers that be I feel like
I just
like with the feminist thing and all it
like it's being over men are being
overruled or overlooked I I agree with
that I think the part the powers that be
if we're we're going to use that for for
lack of a better term I I think yeah the
powers that be are encouraging women to
go into leader leadership positions
because women are easier to manipulate
if you look at everything that's
happened in the world over the last
three years we can't talk about what I'm
referring to on YouTube but I think we
all know if I mention the time period of
2020 to now the majority of tactics that
we used were emotional tactics do it for
Nan
things like that and that's because
women now are the leaders of most
households so if you can manipulate the
women you can manipulate the nation now
because women have the whole say in
everything so I would actually to answer
King's question I don't believe that
women should be encouraged to be leaders
because
when women like you said as well you
know I I generally believe that men are
more logical beings and and
unfortunately as women not even
unfortunately it's a fact as women you
know we are more emotional it's not
unfortunate because that doesn't have to
be a bad thing you know like we said at
the start men and women are good at what
they're good at I don't believe that
leading is what women are good at okay
so can I can I ask sorry can I ask
leading in what capacity that's right
because I just I just yeah literally
like because because I think I think we
need to be so for context purposes
um
generally so I don't believe that a
company that is run by a woman is going
to be profitable I don't believe we're a
company where women are in the majority
of roads that push the progression of
that company I don't believe that
company does as well as it would if it
was headed by a man and also in
households I don't believe that
households that are run by women rather
than the men this is excluding single
mother households because obviously the
women have got to leave those households
right in households where there's a man
and a woman present I think the product
of that household so the children tend
to do better off when the man needs that
that household for context purposes go
ahead yeah I just want to say I just
want to address your comment about
saying that
um about um how um women in leadership
are not as good uh in in just from what
I've seen yeah okay I'm just I don't
really like to talk about personal
experiences but I'm just going to give
my own personal experience
um so before I was an actress
um I was a vice principal of a school I
was probably the one of the youngest
persons ever to be in in senior
leadership okay that was because I was
outstanding in my job I used to have a
record of a hundred percent a star to
see in GCSE three years in a row so I
was made
to to you know and I was successful in
that position because I was better as a
teacher and better as a leader in that
position I I received um a collaboration
from the minister of schools and
education at a very young age when I was
just a trainee teacher
um because of my efforts and because of
my my work ethic
um so it's not like a male or female
thing it is like I'm saying it the
reality is your case is is literally a
French kiss that's the point I was gonna
make
a question when you personalize things
like that then you you kind of throw off
the point because the reality is there
are not many women that can say what
you've said just yeah
you might be just one woman that was
exceptional that that doesn't even
represent even up to 50 but the thing is
and that's not to take away from you
either because if you had what you just
said that is exceptional let's not deny
that three years in a row a star to see
but the thing is is her job her job is a
nurturing role no but you see the
education is actually a very bad example
for you to use because if we were to
look at the state of education ever
since women took over
the UK and the U.S are literally have
some of the worst education policies the
worst Educational Systems that exist in
the world today you look at the state of
education look at if you go on the
streets in the ucan or in the U.S and
just interview people you you would you
would actually be mind blown about the
kind of people that actually have
degrees that come up that's why I say
it's exceptional that you've got those
results because that was what that was
like quite a while ago now so yeah but I
do agree with him about a legit
education has changed yeah what they
gave you did well you know what I'm
saying at the end of the day you can
only do what they give you it's not even
that her role is a nurturing role she's
supposed to teach the kids that's what
wives do I only homeschool that's sort
of work so obviously
there are plenty male teachers as well
women are fit to nurture and teach
exactly so of course it's going to be
well the leadership role they need to be
under the leadership of a man that is my
point also the latest statistics on
teachers um I don't actually know if
this is in America or the UK but they
pretty much reflect each other and it's
something like 15 of teachers are men so
the majority of them are women and I
think that speaks to to what you said uh
women tend to go for those roles because
they're they're less masculine roles I
don't I don't necessarily think that's a
good thing I think we actually need to
encourage more men to be teachers
because of the crisis in fatherlessness
that we're seeing I think we need more
men in positions around children so that
the the kids especially boys who don't
have men to look up to and then have
mentors in place but but that's another
issue can I just can I just say
something quickly so I I agree with with
what what you said about
um about how how in the household right
um um the the man the man is the leader
and the man should be the leader but I
disagree in terms of in just in general
right leadership in general because
a lot of like like King mentioned
something he said that um he said that
men men are are naturally meant to be
leaders okay that may be true however I
still think that women can make great
leaders because a lot of leadership
qualities right that that that that you
would consider as good leadership
qualities can be taught nobody see if it
comes down to Warrior and you've got to
take someone's head off but women ain't
gonna have the same aggression because
if you're talking about leadership
leadership in general yeah
because the no sorry the the example
that um
Christine the example that Christine
gave was
um she she said that she didn't believe
that
um
a company that is that is led by by a
woman or where women make up the
majority of the board of directors
um would would do as well as if a man
was was leading it and I disagree with
that because I I have do you have any
examples
you just said that the reason why you
disagree with it is because the females
can be taught to be leaders but they're
being taught by men therefore men are
better leaders just contradicted
yourself no but what I'm saying is that
women can still be leaving yeah I don't
think she's saying that that men are not
generally better leaders because yeah
I'm agreeing with how men are very
instinctively leaders it's instinctive
however however I I I I I think that it
is it is it is like
just I get what you're saying women
but the reason I made that point I'm
gonna tell you the reason why I made
that point because I would also love to
believe that that's not the case and
that when when women do make up the
majority and when women are spearheading
a company I would love to believe that
women can be taught to be just as in
just as good leaders as say in the same
way that men instinctively do it
however
when you actually look at companies
where things like quotas have been put
in place to encourage more women into
into leadership roles and things like
that Twitter is the example that comes
to mind and when Twitter in 2014 put in
place their quotas
um they put the majority of women in
charge of their Department called trust
and safety
um which is which was the department
that ran a lot of their censorship
programs right when all of this was
happening when women they made up
something like 76 of that department and
a lot of the other departments as well
because there were quotas in place to
encourage women into those departments
um the company was making no money and
also freedom of speech was limited why
because of the point I made that women
are more emotional so we're more easy to
propagate so they could tell the women
oh you you need to censor these people
because it's for the greater good and
women are more likely to sit there and
go well I want to do something for the
greater good because we're emotional
that they would then just go ahead and
do it then when Elon Musk bought Twitter
he got rid of all the quotas which
resulted in a lot of women losing their
jobs now all right that's a shame but
you look at Twitter in the state now
compared to before
Twitter is making money again it's
slowly becoming profitable again and
actually when the men came back into the
roles that they were good at
um Twitter has done a lot better so I I
agree you know
we can't sit here and say no women can
be leaders you know you provided an
exceptional case and there are
exceptional cases but my point is is
that generally
I think
men do it better
one at a time one at a time sorry can I
just quickly sorry sorry apologies
um so I I don't disagree men can do it
better but I still think that women can
also do it very well as well and and
also and also there are bad male leaders
of course agreed of course exactly so so
so so so this this whole thing about uh
about like I understand the point um
understand the point about women being
more emotional and all of that like and
I appreciate that
um but women can still be very great
leaders and and and I I I also don't
think that it's just it's just like the
exceptions like like I think a lot of
women have the capability to actually be
great leaders but I do I do yeah I do I
do understand your point about quotas
though like I I do believe that even
though even though women can be
encouraged to to to take on leadership
roles
um it shouldn't just be handed to them
just because they're women I I do
definitely believe that it should be
given to somebody that actually has the
ability let me say something quickly
yeah I'm gonna have done the whole
argument at longevity yeah longevity of
leaders I'm on a two on two yeah
he's a he's a prime minister now but
she's seen that yeah and the one before
was Boris Johnson the one before that
was list trust the one before that was
Theresa me the two women had the
shortest terms out of the men and women
done but even apart from that that's one
example there's just four examples I
just gave you four examples
it's politics but they're leaders look
at the leaders of the country let me
explain the reason why I said women
shouldn't be encouraged it's not because
I don't think women can't be good
leaders women can be good leaders but
the problem with encouraging women to go
and mass into leadership is that you
guys are forgetting the fact that women
are not built like men for you to Be an
Effective leader there comes you have to
have qualities
there's a kind of pressure that comes in
leadership that women are not built to
handle Act of emotions especially when
you're handling things like companies
where it's literally a dog eat dog wall
yeah and this is the problem with it
when women come into the space of men
they come into this masculine space and
they want to be leaders and then they
get faced with the way men deal with
pressure and they want to complain and
say oh my God the man is doing this the
man is doing that but that's literally
how we men deal with each other come on
so if you're a woman that wants to come
into leadership you have to be able to
come into a world and not be able to
complain about oh this guy is trying to
hit on me this guy is such you can't be
talking about [__] like that because men
have to deal with that [__] as Leaders
so if there's a leader you have to be
willing to take every single [__]
that comes with it which women typically
are not willing to do women would rather
go and complain and say oh this happened
and this happened instead of looking for
the solution behind it so that's just my
that's just and I'm I'm just being very
general I know like I said there are
exceptions
some of the best leaders that are women
go and look at what they what ends up
happening to them they lose and and they
literally become men and and one thing
when I go back to the political side of
things and we're talking about leaders
who runs this thing if they ain't going
to talk about politicians who's leading
or supposed to be leading us as Leaders
I think it's supposed to be leading is
the important word there say that yeah I
think supposed to suppose exactly yeah
you had a point yeah I just want to say
when you said that you you believe that
men are just better leaders generally
generally yeah generally speaking do you
feel this is a a question more of a
question here than a point do you feel
it's because they are given more
opportunities to be leaders that's why
they're better no I I think it's I think
it's scientific biological fact
I think the reason that we live in a
patriarchy is because Nature has built
that way I don't believe that that has
happened by some
patriarchy can become corrupt right
let's not disagree right of course
everything can become corrupt but I
think the reason that we I mean we don't
really live in a patriarch anymore but
for all intents and purposes I think the
reason that the West has mostly been
patriarchies
um is because it works
I think I think it just works and I
think that that's just a law of Nature
and that that's not even that's not even
the complete answer the complete answer
is human beings have evolved through
time through certain experiences that
have built us into what we are the
reason why men control the world in
quotes or the reason why men have built
the word up to be the weight is and
where men are leaders it's not because
we got the opportunities because we took
the opportunity because we were designed
to take the opportunity right from
Evolution when we were living in the
caves the women stayed in the caves and
the men went out to hunt because the
women were more prone to Danger the
woman would have been easy prey to the
to the to the Lions and the cows
but the men were willing to risk their
lives because of the way we were
designed to go out and fight those
dangers without fear and even when we're
scared we still had to do it because it
was responsibility it wasn't handed to
us so when I come up with this idea of
oh it's because men just have this
opportunity men never had any
opportunity even the men today that are
leaders don't getting handed to them
they literally have to fight other men
for every opportunity they get
I I agree with you however however I
agree with you but the angle I'm coming
from is I agree that leadership
generally is a very instinctive thing
that happens to men right a man has the
hormones to want to take charge and I
know that we live in a world where this
kind of masculinity has been demonized
so it's like if you want to take charge
that means you are just a detector but
that's not true like you can actually
take charge for good right however
the way you phrased the question in my
head I'm just like
it's better
to let people dream right and get
wherever it is that they want to get to
right like I will actually encourage
encourage my daughters my daughters to
be the best of themselves like to do the
best of things that they want to do but
I think we're having this conversation
because maybe the the the the the the
Thin Line has actually been you know has
been swallowed right that there is a
difference between man and woman and I
agree with him like men handle stress
differently women most times or
sometimes or many times rather when
they're actually very stressed they
start getting annoyed at everybody so
you're speaking to the point of
encouragement and I hear what you're
saying I agree so let's not say because
we feel that you know men handle it
better even if women can be as good as
them so we shouldn't encourage them then
and I don't really agree with saying
that every woman who is who is a good
leader has lost their masculinity and
and I understand what you are saying but
immediately you just said if somebody
came to mind right I'm Nigerian and the
the managing director of the World Trade
Organization is a woman and she's not I
don't think let me not mischaracterizer
I don't think she's a feminist she she I
think there was a time she said she
still cooks for her husband right I I
think that women can attain a level of
of of of Excellence no one no one is
denying that that is a possibility but
on the point of encouragement I agree
right when you're raising children it's
very important to tell children you know
dream go out there right
but a 40 year old man who has achieved
nothing in his life is morbidly obese
does nothing but say sit in his mom's
basement has no drive to go out and do
anything
because he's still in that idea of
encouragement oh I you know one day I'll
go out and I'll get all of these things
I I think encouragement at a certain
point stops being kind and this speaks
to the point that King was making about
back in in the caveman times if you know
women were to go out we're more
susceptible to Danger like you know if
we was to go out and fight and let's say
the other tribe is all men going out we
would be destroyed at a certain point
encouragement becomes unkind because if
you encourage women to go into a
position where they're more vulnerable
and then they get hurt was it kind to
encourage them to get there in the first
place
you are saying but as long as
and and I agree with you right I I think
I partially agree with you however I
just think that there are things that
people should see for themselves there's
Nuance to it and and yeah I completely
agree that there's Nuance to it as there
is to everything um but how we got here
was was the question of what has has
feminism achieved um and I was hoping
that someone would say contraception but
but no one did so thanks for that guys
now I have to bring it up that's
something that nobody really cares about
no no there's anything about it actually
the majority of women are on
contraception and a lot of the arguments
that I hear in the feminist space of uh
you know I think surrounding feminism a
lot of the the points I hear as well you
know feminism pushed the normalization
of contraception
and I had to think really really long
and hard about this because you know
obviously the reason that we have
contraception now is because women are
more promiscuous women are sleeping
around more so the need for for
contraception is there seemingly that's
what I thought the the need for
contraception came from right but I have
a question is uh the bill created by men
or women
I don't actually know who it was created
by but I do know why it was legalized
and who it was pushed by uh I don't know
where I got the sauce from but when I
was younger I used to get to understand
that pills was created by a bunch of men
basically that it was a main decision
well men invent most things yeah yeah so
men invent most things but I think
what's important to to notice is like
you know you can create something but
whether that passes through legislation
and becomes a norm is a different story
um and I think rather than the event The
Invention itself what's important is how
is that invention used and and why is it
utilized in in one way or the other so
I'm I'm interested to to know does
anyone know why contraception was pushed
by the the feminist movement does it
does anyone know why contraception
became popular because I thought it was
just because well women were sleeping
around more so they needed a way to stop
all the women from from getting pregnant
anyone any thoughts I have maybe an idea
I believe them
it's because you know if a woman don't
have a kid she can go out there in this
world and become you know this uh
masculine type of woman and uh basically
take the role of a man and be the
leadership because you know you don't
have nothing to hold you back I mean
another factor is if you look at it like
a business right contraception generally
uh is a drug like every drug you know
there's money to be made and I and I
think the powers that be the the term
that you're using
um you know if they can push
contraception then they can they can
make more money right and and we all
know when it comes to making money
generally they don't care about your
health um I'm sure I'm sure
that I already made in the beginning
while I have
marketing what you know what I have
talked about a lot of things that are
happening that we consider as being an
anomaly the root is just money marketing
ambulance to make more money it's part
of the the money scheme is part of it as
well but also another it's another
option for women you know what I'm
saying yeah
procreating yes just to slow down from
you know you having a baby and maybe
concentrating on your career yeah your
family and this is this is the problem
with contraception what's the problem I
think that maybe the problem is that
when the woman is the women's mentality
yeah but the outcome is that when a
woman don't have a kid
it will makes you more work as you will
have to yeah but why should you feel
like you need to work if you've got a
good man that's working yeah for you
within your family household or your
family environment yeah I think she's
actually agreeing with you because she's
implying that when women are on
contraception and not having kids
they're spending more time in the
workplace and that gives more money back
to society what I'm saying is that the
whole thing is a whole chain basically
we are basically turning around since in
the beginning and I believe that
everything will be seeing comes back to
some few words that I have pronounced in
the beginning ambulance there's no
balance and there's no we have no
structure anymore we don't know what
it's like to be a man what what is to be
a woman we don't understand you know the
lines are just blurred yeah you know we
have normalized so much things and
people don't know what it's like to be a
man what it's like to be a woman what is
masculinity what is a femininity we're
just mixing everything around and I
think the problem with with
contraception is that it's made so
readily available and like it's free in
this country for anyone under the age of
25 and that even goes so far as down to
girls who are like 12 years old they
don't have to tell the girls and it's
really scary and what's even worse
like the origin of feminism is the
origin behind contraception so uh the
reason that contraception was pushed uh
and like politicized and why it was so
normalized they told everyone was part
of this feminist movement and it was to
empower women and to give women the
ability to have sex like men
um but that that wasn't the case so uh
the the sexual Liberation movement
brought about the normalization of
contraception for women Margaret Sanger
is the first known great birth control
Crusader she founded Planned Parenthood
in America and was the first to promote
contraception for women and here in the
UK we pretty much followed America's
Direction Margaret Sanger was a very
famous person with eugenic propaganda in
various interviews when asked why
Margaret was fighting for women to have
more access to contraception she
provides the following answers
for my view
I believe that there should be no more
babies the most merciful thing a large
family does to one of its infant members
is to kill it
what all of the problems in our world
are a result of overbreeding among the
working class knowledge of birth control
is essentially moral it's General though
prudent practice must lead to a higher
individuality and ultimately a cleaner
race
birth control itself often denounced as
a violation of natural law is nothing
more or less than the facilitation of
the process of weeding out the unfit of
preventing birth of defectives or of
those who will become defectives if we
are to make racial progress this
development of Womanhood must precede
motherhood in every individual woman she
even attempted a ban on childbirth and
campaigned for no more babies this is
the woman who bought you birth control
and abortion that is
I'm sorry
yeah when you said she's the one who
brought so she's the one who who
campaigned for it advocated it she
founded Planned Parenthood she's the
founder of of Planned Parenthood in
America she was the first one to
politicize it talk about it on TV she
she led the revolution that that led to
it being legalized okay but actually
what she's making isn't is doesn't make
any sense then if she's because it
doesn't it's absurd no no she's
contradicting herself because if she's
saying that she's promoting it
um how can she promote something when
she is saying that women should not have
any more babies then they'll they'll be
end of the world so then what's her and
what's really ironic then this woman had
children herself you would think for
something so she's contradicting herself
I hope she didn't kill her children no
no because she deemed her children
Superior because she said anyone who was
working class or of ethnic minority were
what's the word she uses it the point is
that it was targeted at the lower class
and the minorities so and also it was
also a racially targeted move so
basically it it didn't it wasn't meant
to be used by her and her
class of people and what's sickening is
people people don't know this and when
you look at the statistics of of people
who who are getting abortions and are
you know using contraception it's like
the whole idea that um you know people
who own things like Facebook and that
they don't give it to their children
it's that same thing you know the woman
who was pushing this is saying oh for
everyone else but not for me and this
the reason I use this example is because
of the title of the episode do feminists
crave destruction well this was all
pushed under the guy's feminism and
women's empowerment but when we look at
the the history and the origins of it I
mean I think everyone here can agree
it's it's absolutely disgusting and it
screams of Destruction I don't think a
woman could come out nowadays talking
like that just out there and not feel
like Lynch turns in that's all really
intrigued especially with the type of
feministers out nowadays that's unheard
of to be yeah
is not only a problem of feminism but a
problem of uh
yeah Society and also how do you call it
in English
um her social status yes you know
because I would like also to know what
is her background it's what you said
divide and conquer
it's what I'm so sorry I've forgotten
your name interrogation I did know that
I did know that she said the point
interrogation boss is who I'm talking to
she made the point of it's It's divide
and conquer and that speaks to feminism
as a whole you know why was feminism
funded by the Rockefeller families why
was it funded by the CIA because when
you divide people people become weaker
because we're strongest when we're
unified and we're together I'd like to
know how she came up with that that kind
of mentality after having kids
because how do you have kids maybe she
had really misbacks
maybe I don't know how you can come up
with that kind of mentality after having
a child
I mean
it's surprising because like I'm saying
the way she's coming from I don't feel
like it is coming from
um
feminism is coming from another person
but feminism
because we can see that in China or I
don't know if I'm if I'm saying if I'm
talking
um nonsensitivities but I believe that
in China there was also this rule that
people should not be doing more than one
kid for a certain period of time but I
believe that this um this uh this
concept have come with also another type
of mindset not as the same as that woman
but I believe that she come from a
perspective of superiority and uh of uh
the point is that the point is that
every feminism is literally just a tool
that was created
to control people that's the point it's
so but the people that are being
controlled are seeing it as a tool for
Redemption where it literally isn't so
by you buying it to the ideology you're
literally buying into your own
enslavement that's literally what it is
but anyways I'm going to take time to
read out super chat now or do you have
it with you um I think it's best if you
do it you probably have a better
perspective than me all right um I'm
going to read super chat now um
okay um Dakota Saint Laurent um thanks
for being a new member
um see Matheson men's right to vote is
dependent on his duty to Country women's
right to vote should depend on her duty
to family if she divorces cheats or
aborts she should lose that citizenship
rights require responsibility if you
aren't responsible you don't deserve the
rights see matters in since always go
sins always go right for the egalitarian
perspective because it gives women a way
out
okay um C Matheson feminists have no
idea that this is going to come back and
hit them in the face if you make it
illegal for men to kiss women they are
going to stop kissing women every action
has a reaction see Madison bring back
shaming these Sims and three of us need
it
cruxy
um Christine please look into the work
of Edward Dutton Pearl's friend Rachel
Wilson interviewed him and largely
agreed with him on his understanding of
feminism he is very smart and on a wide
range
dog MPA good thing about feminism is
that it's freedmen from our traditional
roles in society men don't have to be
packed males for women anymore men don't
owe women resources time attention any
of it
savix all data we consume from from our
individual experiences and external
observation of others is the information
that our perceptions are formed from
it's a much grander grander example of
monkey see monkey do
Vegas this is this is BS I've never met
a woman that was faithful eighty percent
of the men who introduced me to their
wives have offered me sex especially if
their wives have been drinking PS I'm
100 straight
um see Matheson kiss is not a French
kiss she's a diversity hire
um dragon dragon stallion 90 of
well-known chefs in bracket with staff
are males
10 match 10 Mitra men risk 10 major
thanks for the hundred dollar Super Chat
um let's give it 100 Super Chat
um balling men respond to respect men
respond and respect strength and Brute
Force men lead men enough said work see
matosin two percent of two percent women
in trucking jobs why don't women want to
leave transportation
dog MPA black women in the U.S make up
eight percent of the population but make
up forty percent of the abortion of the
abortions Margaret Sanger succeeded in
her vision for wiping out black babies
enter black dragon leadership isn't
something you give to someone it's
something we take much like
responsibility accountability and pride
men must earn everything in life while
women are simply handed everything
90 free top high
them women are factual but never honest
okay yeah that's it
thank you for that guys I'm definitely
gonna look into that guy I've not heard
of him so thanks for that
um okay so I'm gonna just ask some
general questions about feminism now
um is body positivity really positive
we're going to start here and and go
around body positivity in what way do
you mean so body positivity
body positivity is is the whole thing
that we're seeing where I mentioned
women who are 300 pounds uh being on the
front page of Sports Illustration
magazines
like I said I promote health is wealth
like I just believe that everybody goes
for a certain time in life where they
might lose themselves or whatever but I
still believe that like you should try
and portray yourself in the best way
possible physical form throughout your
life just see what I'm saying and you
should kind of be an example to people
just like I'm saying because
I think health is like treating your
body good and looking after yourself is
a is a sign of of discipline and focus
and it kind of shows the kind of
character you are or what kind of
qualities that you possess as a person
so I don't believe that Royal like if
you're just going to be somebody that
just likes to indulge and not really
take responsibility for your health is
is a positive thing to be honest what
what do you think what was the question
is body positivity a good thing body
positivity so body positivity is is what
we see right now where um
you ask women rate yourselves on a scale
of one to ten right purely on physical
appearance
nothing to do with your personality or
your value as a human being what do you
think others would rate you on a scale
of one to ten from the outside and they
will say 10 yeah and they will say
because well I'm body positive and
because I believe I'm a 10 I'm saying do
you think this is a good thing do you
think it's a good thing to promote body
positivity
depends how they're promoting it and
because a lot of women have got their
bodies done and that's boosted their ego
which is then and is that a good thing
I don't condone it just walk with what
why don't you condone it why why are you
doing that like I just believe that
women just need to just be themselves
too you are be who God created you to be
but then it's like it will always Resort
back to Trends it will always Resort
back to them seeing American women doing
it and they're doing these things so we
can do it over here I believe so because
what would literally make you want to
wake up one day and say I want to go and
get my bum done I want to go and get my
tits done way but then your ego's now
been driven to a higher position now
because people are eating you now so
that's that's I just don't believe me
some women do have the need and and and
it is maybe a necessity for them to feel
like they need to do these things to
enhance because for confidence Clarity
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah some women do
actually do food like they they boost
their confidence exactly they need a
confidence boost but my question is is
that boost in confidence a good thing if
it is I do think if it I think it's a
good thing for their self-esteem because
I don't think anybody should feel like
they're depressed and left because they
should be depressed throughout their
life but it's the way around of that
inflation of the ego or is the way
around of that
changing your circumstances
I think go to I I think go to the gym go
to the gym and work on your body that
way why do you have to go and get these
things to get validation and there are a
lot of downsides of it as well no I
completely hear you okay uh I just want
to address both of their points okay so
I totally agree with him with him he's
saying about
um it's your health it's like that is
you know when you're saying when you
mentioned before about Buzz body
positivity about 300 pounds and is that
okay to promote that and he is saying
well promote your health because I used
to be 120 kilos okay do you happen to
know how much that is in uh kg or stone
yeah that is kg 120 okay sorry yeah I
don't know where I am what is it like a
19 maybe he's done something like that
okay okay yeah but that didn't what did
that bring me that brought me like
Health complications and if I see like
obviously now in social media when
you're saying about this and how it's
okay to be like that but it's not
because your health it does affect your
health and it does like bring on things
like heart disease and and there's so
many other cardiovascular and loads of
other things like that so it shouldn't
be like
um uh and even from a medical point of
view even from a scientific or a person
who what about your point about
representation
are they just presenting
larger women in the space that's not a
positive representation
I agree but that's not what these media
companies think we really care about the
media to be honest people are getting
sucked by the media are brainwashed yeah
so really and truly if you're gonna sit
there and think oh the media is telling
me something that's positive but it
doesn't look positive like ComEd like
that's what I'm saying like use your
brain and people aren't using them yeah
and I just want to address his point
when he's saying that like he doesn't he
obviously doesn't condone it and he
thinks that what was the word that you
used you said
um about like validation validation
right seeking validation yes seeking
validation but do you not feel
um obviously because you put on the
topic of femininity and feminism do you
not feel that
um
also they're not doing it not just for
themselves because they feel like males
and that's what the men want so that's
the reason that's another reason yeah
that's another reason why they're doing
it because they feel like that is what
has become Beauty now and it will draw
more attention for the men yeah look at
them yeah okay but I I think that shows
a lack of self-esteem esteem
yeah a lack of actually
like just knowing who you are knowing
your identity and and being confident in
your identity so yeah but I'll take my
turn I kind of feel like that takes away
from you being a woman when you feel
like that you have to do these things to
keep up well it speaks to the point of I
promiscuity doesn't it because if if
women are doing it uh because they feel
like they have to do it to get the
attention of men well that speaks to to
the whole thing this is because feminism
has blurred the lines between what men
find sexually attractive and what men
actually look for in a good long-term
partner and the problem is now
um a lot of women don't know the
difference between what men are sexually
attracted to and what men actually want
so they will go and do all of this stuff
get all of this work done and then
Wonder well I've got 20 000 likes on
Instagram but why don't I have a husband
um so there's the whole issue away from
their unique identity as a person yeah
because you just look like everybody
else in them yeah exactly a common copy
of somebody that you think looks
attractive in a magazine but half the
time I don't care about that men care
about what's in your brain I'm saying
and how your how you're articulate
yourself exactly because like if you're
just gonna go and get collagen in your
lips or or put
fat in your face and for your ass
there's no there's no yeah there's no
uniqueness to that just what I'm saying
interrogation boss what do you think
um what I think is that um coming to the
point that you made I think females just
don't want to accept that they don't
naturally have it I think females
actually doing the surgery it is what
Mel's like what they like it naturally
and these fields are trying to copy that
because I know they don't have it
naturally and they can't actually just
live with I don't have this naturally so
they just try to get it fakely I don't
realize it looks fake obviously they
don't like it and in terms of um your
original question which was what was
your original question is body
positivity a good thing oh I think
that's been misconstrued um completely
um body positivity is a good thing for
healthy bodies of course but people are
now misconstruing it and thinking that
300 pounds now it's now a busy a body
positivity positive thing and I think
the issue is not anything outside of
that is seen as fat shaming when
actually I think it's kinda to tell them
you're fat than it is to say that's
beautiful because you say that's
beautiful it's positive reinforcement
you're reinforcing the behavior so
they're going to get fat and fat are
thinking I'm beautiful and then they're
dead and people will say that the love
of telling them oh but it's confidence
and and we care about how you feel they
think that's love but that's not love if
you're hurting them exactly and it comes
down to like you were saying about that
being diverse and all of these things
like people want to feel like
representation presentation they feel
like they want to be they want to fit
into a certain demograph of of of of of
of people which I just believe that we
know what good and we know what spider
we know it's healthy we know what's
unhealthy like to a logical state of
mind so why do we then press the issue
of making bigger people seem like
they're better off that way and I would
even say that oh sorry besides the
feminazis um have always just hijacked
many things in society so for instance
body positivity
initially was meant to be for people
that for instance maybe had an arm
chopped off and then they were
encouraged to accept themselves and love
themselves the way they are or maybe
someone that had a scar on their face or
was it a wheelchair disabled exactly
that's literally what body positivity
was meant to be just encourage my friend
with the agendas that have been pushed
now it's all about okay yeah
um people are now going to get these
defects done on themselves
willfully and now trying to use body
positivity as a way to mask their
insecurities yeah so that's why yeah and
and just on that point I was going to
say that because I think you mentioned
uh confidence and I was just going to
say that it's a false confidence that
it's giving them as well because at the
end of the day the the lack of
self-esteem that that they they feel
intrinsically will still be there
regardless of of whatever like
encouragement they may get from from
from I don't know Society or
people who push body positivity
what do you think
Oh Me ibilala Is My Name by the way
thank you so
um I believe that loving yourself at
every stages of your life is the most
important
but uh when it comes to the question if
I agree with the body positivity that we
are trying to push in this Society
personally I don't really agree with the
outcome because myself as a young adult
I notice how Trends are changing every
six months there's always something new
there's always
something that you need to upgrade up
about yourself or go or take it out
wherever
so I believe in loving yourself just the
way you are being confident and um
yeah being confident and being friends
yeah and for me the most important when
it comes to body positive positivity is
your health
are you healthy are you feeling okay by
doing your daily task if not identify
the problem solve it and if you're happy
with it then that's it I think the
majority of people that get overweight
become unhappy yeah so that in a
nutshell tells you tells you that
but the positivity isn't something
that's going to be very positive in your
life if we're talking about having
longevity in life you know what I'm
saying because you are then going to
then
come in in facing some kind of
conditions that's gonna then like
yeah
overweight and also too skinny because a
certain point in mind nobody promotes
skinny I was uh I was overweight and I
was also too skinny and uh both a stream
I felt unhealthy because when I was
overweight I couldn't do enough and I
was when I was too skinny I was very
weak but I was looking what people call
me and that's another thing I was really
skeleton I remember at this time the
reason why I was very scholaritic is
because I I have um eating disorder I
couldn't eat but when people see me
after a long time I think it looks cool
the first thing they say oh you look so
beautiful I feel like you're so happy
lately but the reality is that at that
time I was so unwell that my brain the
way it works is not is me not having any
appetite
any willing to eat and feed myself in
order to have the energy to go after my
daily task because we're in society here
especially that like women have become
so like
not wanting to do [__] like in in
regards to looking after themselves that
they've lost themselves in a way here
that like even down to the fashion
industry when every every woman was made
to be skinny and the average women
weren't skinny supermodel women so now
all of a sudden for the average woman
that is overweight we had to make a
category for them or or to to kind of
make them feel appreciated by and to
reinforce them to to continue to be that
way exactly and because that is that is
a fact a majority of us women nowadays
are are overweight
um and I think yeah I think the the body
positivity is just a way of reinforcing
that because of this whole idea of that
you know if you divide people if you
keep people weak you have people
unhealthy that they're easier to control
they're easy to manipulate um and also
also they're easier to fall and it's
another part of society that wasn't
listened to yeah and now all of a sudden
now because it's popular to be big now
we can listen to these big women and
take in what they're saying and it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's now become
a norm it's also a distraction because
it speaks to the the whole idea of well
if all of your basic needs are met um it
speaks to Indulgence if you can get
people to to indulge in something that's
unhealthy
um well they're not paying attention to
say The Wider issues in the world
because they're too busy with their face
and a hamburger like
but yeah to continue is body positivity
a good thing
um your lovely wife is it adiola adiola
yeah
um yeah so I I mean I've chipped in here
and there but um essentially I would say
it's not a good thing
um in terms of the the way the way it is
but the way it is being presented right
now I mean King mentioned
um um the root of it
um um and and why it kind of came about
in the first place but how it is right
now I would say it's not a good thing
because it it is encouraging
um people women especially to to again
indulge in kind of unhealthy unhealthy
habits and to continue being unhealthy
as well and and it is also I believe
anyway that it is also further
destroying the the self-esteem of women
because because
a lot of a lot of women that they say
that
that may say that they are body positive
or or they are
um
kind of just just just
try it trying to embody that right like
they have self-esteem issues already and
and encouraging encouraging them in that
isn't helping them but it is just taking
them further down that rabbit hole
yeah I think so body positivity was
meant to be like encouraging people to
accept themselves the way they are now
especially those with unfortunate
circumstances like absolutely now the
way they are is the not because people
should be any way that they want but
just the fact that probably some people
have a big nose and they don't like it
you know some people bully them about
that and they're gonna accept that right
but when it gets to like body sizes
that's number one I mean that's
absolutely wrong
um that's something that I just find
very deceptive and it just shows like
the power of the media I don't think
people really realize how powerful the
media is right I I I did mass
communication you know in uni and and
the media can make you think things you
don't want to think yes the media can
make you feel things you don't want to
feel and that's why I understand I'm not
saying I'm not saying we should be so
skeptical about the media but we should
not be too trusting about the things
that we see because literally agendas
can be set right for people to talk
about certain things and make you start
talking about that thing and um and I'm
saying that because like that's just one
aspect of body positivity then when we
look at like women going online you know
um going naked and they say you know
yeah I'm just showing off my body it's
making me feel good and I'm like if you
really need to show it off
to feel good are you really free does
that make sense your point yeah I just
want to make a point like to add on to
the point about talking about the media
so it's a good point that we we didn't
really talk about the media too much
um so
um I totally agree with that um about
having an agenda because I used to work
in the media I used to be a news anchor
a political news anchor so I do know
obviously the inside of it and it is all
based at Agenda the news is put on the
headlines is put on by someone who is
picking and choosing what headlines to
put on so of course it absolutely is
that
um and to speak to to your point I I
absolutely think we should be skeptical
about the media go check out my YouTube
channel debunking the lunacy you'll find
the episode there because when you look
into the
how the media became to be what it is
um and you look at things like
propaganda uh it speaks to what you said
it is all very much by Design
um
and it's really dark actually I mean
again
I know I shouldn't keep going back to
this point because if any of us utter
the word of what I'm talking about this
video is going to probably get taken
down but the time period between 2020
and and now
um yeah propaganda and it was that that
kind of woke me up to the true essence
of media and I completely cut off all
media Outlets like news things like that
I even tell my parents my parents are of
the older generation my dad's almost 17
my mum's in her 60s and they grew up
with this stuff and so people are kind
of oblivious to it and I had to tell
them like you know stop watching the
news you know my mom would say have you
heard about this and I'm like stop
watching it it's getting in your head
it's ruining your day
the thing is the thing is like a lot of
things that are broadcast to us should
just be taken with a pinch of salt like
me personally I don't like to conform to
anything the government really says
because from I've been born I've never
really seen the government like help my
family in ways that I thought was
beneficial to us so why should I then
believe anything that really true you're
gonna tell me on a whim just say I'm
saying so I pretty much cover myself I
told my people just do what you've what
you want in life because really and
truly there's no like there are
boundaries within laws but within reason
and there's a lot of people that do
negative and still win and there's a lot
of people that do good or lose so that I
don't really see a wrong or right in
life as long as you self-fulfill
yourself and you're happy and you're not
you're not hurting anybody then just do
you because you can't sit down and wait
for No government to tell you nothing or
you know I'm saying like I could I could
die tomorrow and I'll still be in debt
to certain things it's not going to
change you see what I'm saying so why
are we so you know I'm saying cool up
yeah people are so used to complying
that's why yeah so one thing that I
wanted to quickly against is that I want
also to talk about the fact that there
is actually body but positivity and uh
also the negative side of it and I
believe that to have the proper balance
of it we need to think about Bond body
positivity with the condition of your
health if you pair that two together
you're gonna actually have the right
state of mind because if you
are happy with how you look it's not a
problem but are you healthy if you're
not healthy and you are just happy with
how you look without working on actually
your health I don't think that is
something positive yeah and I believe
that it's something that is more project
on the social media we completely
um forget the health part
because like I said I believe you should
love yourself at every stages like I
said that's why I use the word stages
you know so you maybe have certain
condition that you need to fix but that
doesn't mean that you don't need to see
somebody like you on a TV you you still
need um representation for you to feel
that you're not alone
and there's nothing wrong with it but if
you know that you're unhealthy please do
something about that it's not good to
stay like that and talk about oh yeah I
am how I am and I say and continue to
suffer you are hurting yourself you are
not doing that to anybody positivity
Health together is the real body
positivity no matter how you look
because no matter how you look you can
even be skinny if you're not healthy you
are not doing uh the body positivity you
know what got me yeah like but I don't
know if anyone heard about this but
lizzo yeah got done for fat shaving like
how does that happen
like for real like like you're supposed
to be somebody that they they that they
um they promote through fat shaming I
mean through body positivity but then
you get done for fat shame like and that
that is just that's my moment yeah I was
pretty uh for someone who was the sort
of face of body positivity I was pretty
shocked when that came out too but we'll
have to keep following that particular
case uh because it is still very much in
process and uh we all know the trouble
with cases of accusations so let's keep
following that one but uh that will be
um one second um another hundred dollar
Super Chat from things
thank you
I'll say this once ladies less is more
um C Matheson skeletic
okay but um um also I just wanted to
point out that I like what you said
about television yeah that's actually I
actually like that I'll start using that
[Laughter]
yes
this language has evolved so much to the
point where it's almost like magic like
there are things that happen within the
scope of language that I find very
fascinating like you said television why
do you think it's also called TV
programming yeah come on because we're
in programs
like yeah like I've got a point I've got
I've got an episode of one of my friends
podcasts where I'm actually talking
about how we got Pro how we are
programmed like the things we see to the
things we do to the things we wear you
say I'm saying like I even stopped
wearing certain brands because I've got
my own because I only stand for what I
stand for and and to be real I don't
like the the connotations that come with
a lot of the brands that are out there
now and a lot of the things that we
indulge in because it's a lot of it is
is Masonic or you know I'm saying just
negative to our energy you say I'm
saying we don't even realize what some
of these things do to us as people when
we're following certain things certain
things certain Trends and you know I'm
saying when we're listening to certain
things like when I sit down and I listen
to a lot of people talk I'm actually
listening to the language that people
are using because a lot of the things
that people say skim over our heads and
we're not actually taking in the full
root of what people are saying to us or
how they're trying to manipulate us you
see what I'm saying so when you're
having conversations in terms of people
listen to the language that people are
using you see them break it down and
you'll definitely come to some kind of
definitive answer of where they're going
with their messages and how you should
take it in and see what I'm saying yeah
no I completely agree and I'm I'm
actually
pleasantly surprised that everyone here
is pretty aware of that it's uh not
often that we get a panel like that and
so yeah we're gonna close the show there
I'm gonna go around the room and ask for
some final thoughts if you have any
socials or businesses or any Endeavors
that you want to plug now is your time
to do so
oh final thoughts um so basically I just
I I think that people should think for
themselves women
um yeah should think for themselves and
many times the things that they really
present to people especially on the
media mainstream media like we said you
think that they are benefiting you but
they are also benefiting from you
thinking that you are benefiting from it
does that make sense so it's only when
you actually think and you think for
yourself right and I think it's Dave
Chappelle actually said that one of the
one of the best way to get attention is
by by being a victim by claiming
victimhood right I'm not saying that
women are not marginalized in certain
areas they are but I also don't think
that modern day feminism is actually an
answer and um yeah my social was just
Solomon
um Solomon underscore Buchi on Twitter
and on Instagram
yeah
um final thoughts hmm
I I think yeah I don't think I don't
think I have much much to add to be
honest
um but yeah I just I just really hope um
that that anybody watching this who who
who who maybe is a feminist and has been
thinking that way that I guess you just
reflect
um and just and just really consider how
much
of the movement you know and what the
movement is actually trying to achieve
um and yeah so I'll just I'll just leave
it there to be honest
um and yeah my socials are just at
your Lyrica
I record yeah adiola okay yeah that's it
that's all my final thoughts are two
things first of all I would invite
everybody to start
more as being less of a follower and
obviously I start questioning stuff so
whenever that has been present to you
look into it and be audacious enough to
question it
because I believe that that's the
difference with the Gen Z we question
stuff even stuff that are allowed to not
be questioned we look into it and we ask
each other
ourselves first of all doesn't actually
benefit me and I joined the point of the
sir
don't just uh agree with everything
because the reality is that a lot of
rules that are made in the society looks
like it benefits us but it's all a trap
again into something for us to never go
out of it so
the second point is uh to not be scared
to research like the lady Christine you
did an amazing job by Sir going the
route think of uh yeah of the source of
um National Organization for Women can
now and uh
let us know what is actually the source
of it which is shocking so once again
question everything don't be just a
follower think for it don't be
questioned don't be afraid to ask
questions and have boundaries for
yourself and know your limits and you
will be fine you will figure it out like
uh daddy said can you remember Sisley
said we are all here to learn to make
mistake and learn so it's not important
to do a mistake but learn from it and
move on yeah
as my solution is
thank you very much
uh the final thoughts are is that
throughout this whole conversation we
have all identified a lot of problems Us
in the world today in society and it's
good all and well that we can identify
these problems but there needs to be
some sort of a solution
so that will be my final thoughts and
interrogation boss and tick tock
plug this Lima
um yeah there's not much really to add
like they all made like a really
um valid and uh point the only thing
just to cut it short that uh empowered
women Empower women
um and my social is to slim underscore
Russell
um just I want to make a like a small
shout out that as part of a Miss Great
Britain competition I'm raising funds
for two Charities Cancer Research UK and
Alex's wish which is uh duchenne's
disease was predominantly actually
affects boys and their life expectancy
is only up until 13 years old and I'm
only asking for a donation of Maximum
one pound per person so it the links are
in my bio in my Instagram social to
Slimer underscore Brazil thank you
um my final thoughts are a lot of people
need to stop trying to trade places to
be someone that they're not and a lot of
people in society change themselves to
suit The Narrative of other people and
social media a lot of people need to do
the inner work heal from the core
um and find them again because
everyone's just been brandished and just
changed them and they've lost their
comparison is the thief of Joy yes and
they've all lost their true identity it
then creates mental health and mental
health is something I would say I don't
deem it as a bad thing because we go to
the gym to gain our muscles and nurture
our body why don't we all nurture our
minds to become a better version of
ourselves and I understand and it's very
sentimental to me because being a mental
health sufferer it hurts and I've done
the work on myself and I'm very very
proud and I do actually have an
organization that's now been a running
called power up and that in insights we
like to charge our phone and power our
phones up every day why don't we power
ourselves up charge ourselves up so I
will do the best I can do and I tell my
kids every morning power up instead of
good morning so yeah that's it on a
positive scale
um my socials are jab underscore the
Rouge and yeah everyone stay positive
and well done
cool
um my final thought would be
to this you know
in life describe with a purpose you know
we're like oh tomorrow's on promise
though everybody thinks we're here till
the end of time which I'm saying like
just just if you're spiritual and you're
good lead then pray to your God if if
you're not pray to yourself and just
trying to enhance and be better as a
person in life and you know just try and
and and and and leave with a legacy if
if that's what if that's what you're
trying to do in life
um as well as that
um can check me out my socials I don't
really like to be followed on social
media to be honest so if you fired me
you fired me my name is dng dirty cash
my clothing Line's envious I had no
vision seems impossible and Hip-Hop
ain't that sharp BSF shout all My
Virgins everyone has locked in chat
Christine Paul's not here shout out to
her for hosting the platform King behind
the scene is holding it down so I'm
saying and security keep everything
litty so yeah man this is that really
but um yeah man it was a pleasure to be
on here and meet everybody in here their
different opinions and views on uh on on
feminism and the subjects that we've
spoken and hopefully you know whoever's
watching this and he got a good insight
and some good content out of it as well
man so hopefully I'll be back on this as
well because I like to talk my [__] on
it but um yeah it's good and shout out
to everybody that I know that's been on
here as well my guys have been on it so
yeah well thank you all so much for
coming this was actually my first time
hosting the show so thank you
open-minded and yeah we've had a great
conversation here um I was very nervous
I think you could probably tell at the
start when my voice kept breaking every
two seconds oh we made it we got to the
end we're here and be sure to like And
subscribe to the channel go check out my
channel Christine Grace Smith
um I have a series called debunking the
lunacy where I discuss many of the
topics that we've discussed here today
uh Health feminism democracy the media
and yes if that sounds like something
you'd be interested in go check it out
and yeah if you want ladies to come your
way you need a babe magnet in your life
as courtesy of the audacity Network go
by your women shouldn't vote t-shirt
guaranteed to have all the ladies
looking your way and yeah thank you all
so much for coming again and we will see
you in the next one
peace